[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau live salut Vlad salut Kep salut
les francophonie alors là je suis très
très bien Vlad parce qu'a écrit Étienne
bacros sous mon nom parce que Étienne va
me remplacer donc bon je j'utilise un
petit peu ce pseudonyme pendant quelques
minutes pour pour l'intro de la partie
et la partie qui débute par E4 Vlad
prévisible je pense d'ici jusqu'à la fin
du match
sans aucun doute il y a on voit
continuer avec les intimars parce que
deux fois elle est obtenue un
bonavantage deux fois il était clair que
son adversaire n'est pas tout à fait à
l'aise quoi dans son plat quoi comme je
sais pas comment dire
dans son assiette et donc je prévois que
donc il y a avec les bons ça va toujours
être 4 etc et d'ailleurs je suis très
très impressionné par les prépas de Ding
avec les Blancs et je suis dessus par
son choix de
[Musique]
faut savoir ça d'ailleurs je pense que
historiquement parlant les Françaises le
virtuel la défense française n'a jamais
été senti aussi bien que maintenant
ouais bah d'ailleurs c'est un des
répertoires principaux de Baki qui va
venir voilà qui s'est mis à la française
le plus souvent en fait et le jeu le
plus souvent par exemple rien que compte
grichou qui l'a joué peut-être quatre
parties ici dans cette position il joue
toujours comme les GF3 et il y avait
plusieurs parties compteurs Sacha après
CD qu'on va lire des cartes que vous
voulez epsys
dans ce genre vous dodo parce que sur
ces trois je suppose
au lieu de photos
par contre par contre comme c'est un
match pour le Coran je prévois une ligne
ici Yann robette je prévois une ligne
peut-être plus facile à jouer avec le
noir comme ce décor
très solide blindé une forteresse donc
carrément ce qu'il faut il faut faire
dans un tel match est d'ailleurs
il a joué ça au championnat d'Europe et
sur fouder 7 il y a pas cavalier 3
est à plus la case D7 alors plutôt pas
que 6 pour cette raison plutôt
parce qu'en fait on a analysé ça il y a
pas longtemps comme bac il a joué
moi je pense pas que dingue nouveau dans
cette ouverture en fait je pense qu'il a
joué lorsque il était jaune je pense de
toute manière c'est exactement ce qu'il
faut faire il faut pas avoir trop peur
de speed stop pendant le match si ça
marche pas ça marche pas et vaut mieux
changer je
salue cette décision qui n'est pas
facile à faire pendant le match
ouais mais il était peut-être obligé
aussi
non ça attendait plutôt une Sicilienne
oui mais le problème c'est que dingue
peut-être elle est votre peur de
défendre son droit concerné peau qui
joue vite et c'est l'un de ses meilleurs
éléments donc il vit crier il veut
toujours crier une position solide sauf
il veut pas qu'il y a trop de dangereux
pour son roi en fait maintenant
une grosse ligne mais Yan répète ce
qu'il fait ce dernier temps me lève
c'est que normalement est considéré
comme une ligne à ce mode d'est pour les
bras qui avait égalisé assez facilement
ce que je prévois aujourd'hui en fait
quoique s'il faut que vous les F6 il
rajoute une partie parce que à eux dès
que les dessins que vous voulez dire
trois à ce que je montrais c'est pas que
les bons sont mieux c'est juste toutes
les pièces sur son sur l'échiquier et ça
joue quoi voilà
il a préparé quelque chose on va voir
quoi exactement ah tiens il répète il
répète plutôt Sacha alors ok
sans aucun doute
sans trop réfléchir de parce que ici je
pense E5 plutôt non
F4 marche pas ici c'est très important
que le ça marche 4 échec le classique
des Françaises et comme F4 marche pas à
cause de ce que nous vient de montrer
dans ce cas-là
c'est une bonne française ça pour les
noirs très bon d'ailleurs ok peut-être
tu peux montrer que après dans les
positionner au centre de cette colère
que les saucisses bossaient important
que le noir menace fois 6 fois 6 dans
mon 5
après genre fout des trois fois six fois
6 dans ma 5 échecs ou des deux dames 36
ouais tu récupères le foot
je suppose
et Mathieu dit que Ed on peut jouer dame
prend des 5 aussi
c'est un ex grand coup c'est juste que
maintenant il essaie de éviter à cause
de quoi
le cavalier n'est pas trop bien placé
avant de sauter d'ailleurs après Eden
et le pion isolé avec ed il est pas du
tout jouable ici
si tu l'ouvres la structure C2 est pas
en E2 des fois c'est cool de jouer c'est
plus gros
suite sans rajouter se décoller de 4
ici par exemple
3 par exemple d'imbo 6
et avant Alfa zéro afin avant stockfish
avant tout ce qui renvoie maintenant
les les êtres humains ont compris que
les bons ont une grosse compensation à
long terme
je pense que c'est le meilleur coup à
l'époque quand je veux jouer c'était un
petit coup
en fait c'est quoi l'idée de A3 les amis
c'est parce que si vous faites dans A4
avec l'idée de transférer la dame sur G4
ou elle est bien il y a dans 4 donc à 3
si vous voulez c'est un coup comme quoi
modeste en fait agressif parce que
agressif on prépare dame
j'ai toujours su en fait parce qu'à
l'époque où je jouais c'était pas pas
réputé comme le meilleur
mais c'est comment dire
ce nombre de choses que tu préfères aux
échecs avec les points de transférer ta
Dour sur les deux j'ai toujours pensé
dans la structure française que ramener
la dame en G4 c'était
tu le fais pour tous les moyens tu peux
faire dames des deux d'un F4 dame G4 tu
peux faire cavalier 1 dmg4 cavalier F3
tu peux entamer tout un tas de gens oui
prêt me prend des cinq comme prévu et
donc là tu t'attends à cavalier prend
c'est jouer à tempo par dingly Rennes
alors au moins deux parties je pense
plutôt toi
mais pour grichou que
de deux fausses ce que je dis il y a 5
minutes je pense une a été sûrement à
gagner par un époque une gagne par
grichure mais peut-être n'est pas réussi
de gagner deux fois possible je me
rappelle le vaguement en fait
maintenant pourquoi quand il est 3
d'ailleurs c'est logique non
veulent stopper 5 et donc
après que DF3 plutôt plus tard les Noirs
seront plus ou moins obligés de trouver
les moyens de je précise pour ça
résoudre le problème éternel du Fou ce 8
dans les Françaises je parle dans les
Gambie dedans
oui Jeanne
puis on prend Damme
donc alors après dans E2 comme tu viens
de montrer je vote pour
je vote pour non non je pense que tu as
montré
j'ai fait rock et dame
ce 7 je pense
c'est plus ou moins de ce style là qui
les ont joué en fait
je pense objectivement les bonnes non
pas grand chose voire rien mais Yann
aime se positionner quoi ça a été bien
scanné par l'équipe
tu pourrais si tu avais envie
bon là évidemment Yann il connaît mais
simplement il réfléchit
la préparation possible de dingleren
parce que la française c'est aussi
arrivé comme une surprise pour lui même
si son équipe pouvait se douter que qui
changerait d’ingeren mais à mon avis ils
ont plus travaillé des Sicile
ils ont travaillé quelque chose bon il
se répète alors
donc déjà je pense c'est visible il est
pas trop content de ce qui m'aversaire a
choisi comme le vertu parce que bien sûr
il n'a pas rempoté ce qu'il connaît
avant la partie en général je dois dire
que depuis très longtemps mon frère
depuis que je suis venu aux échecs
presque cavalier de deux ou troisièmes
contre les Françaises considéré comme
modeste donc c'est plutôt cavalier 3 ou
3e ou E5 récemment Ed est devenu
populaire aussi
donc il provoque pas fou de deux joueurs
possède tout de suite donc c'est quoi la
différence le fouille paraît mieux en
c'est un camp des deux mais c'est quoi
la ce qui est vraiment une différence de
toute façon il va devoir sortir ce fou
bah les différences que d'un côté les
Blancs n'ont pas gagné en demi-tour le
développement oui de l'autre côté
il y aura plus de variantes ou le
cavalier des cadres
vont être emprise parce que n'est pas
des fadio par la dame dedans quoi donc
bon ok c'est comment
sujet donc une chose de coeur pour par
contre quand si on fait foudre il y a un
peu plus de cavaliers B4 aussi
c'était contrôlé par le fou des deux et
beaucoup moins de beaucoup moins de
raison de rêver sur les grandes rock
pour les
grands rock c'est plus compliqué ouais
mais disons que tu fasses fouder 3
est-ce que tu fais cavalier B4 direct
bah ça donne la vie
en essayant de jouer C3 après genre se
dire ah tiens
ok ça c'est important parce que si t'as
pas E5 ça aurait pu être merci pour
faire le candide parce que tu as vu au
sein bien sûr merci merci
comme ça j'ai l'habitude de me les
prendre en fait
franchement quand on regarde cette
position là on se demande quand même bon
pourquoi faire football
ça paraît pas si logique que ça en fait
c'est un coup utile dans ce cas là il
voit faire quoi là bah normalement ce 3
alors
justement
quelque chose comme danseuse mais tu
sais que je peux même me permettre cette
truc là avec les Noirs
mais ceux qui le font sont peu nombreux
mais tu peux te permettre tu peux te
permettre dans ces cas-là il faudrait
que tu prouves quelque chose plus tard
forcément pas forcément théorie de Fabi
en fait quand tu joues dans une majorité
comme ça trois contre deux les pions A
et C c'est pas moins bien que A et B
ah ferme bibi
ça t'a fait très très mal non
partir d'un moment donné il faut que je
commence de noter vos théories parce que
jamais appris 4,5 déjà pendant ce
jour-là en fait
c'est vraiment très fort
d'accord
montrons on peut te erreur à nos
spectateurs deux exemples vas-y tank
III
D46
attaquer le roi adverse ou sinon
quatre RC6 des cadres de 5 quand le S3
de e que le 4 que les 6 collectif GF
maintenant si collector donc les bonjour
C3 en attendant
je crois que les décède faut que je
doute dans ce 7 Pyro grandeur
les bons vont m'écraser sur l'île dedans
mais donc oui peut-être que si Ding il a
la théorie du Fab
ou des trois rock qui avait laissé si tu
peux te permettre
qui avait laissé 6 baisser on a oublié
de faire ces trois pardon ce que j'ai
oublié ce que j'irai jamais
quand tu pousses ta majorité c'est que
en fait ce pion il peut venir en C5 et
l'autre je comprends bien
je comprends ça m'est arrivé de gagner
des finales comme ça en fait
et genre enfin en finale de pion je veux
dire si tu enlèves toutes les pièces et
ok je sais très bien pourquoi je l'évite
en fait c'est parce que j'ai été touché
par une partie intérieure
ski et ok
mesdames et messieurs
c'est quoi ce livre d'ailleurs très beau
livre professionnel
les professionnels comme le film
professionnel avec Jean-Paul Belmondo
alors d'ailleurs juste pour dire
première ligne de l'ordi cavalier c'est
6 quand même oui bon fabli
je me sens pitié
tu te prends du fabibi dans la gueule
t'es pas bien
mais bon
mais après tu le vois toi tous les jours
dans le dans ta piole
on parle souvent de the virtuel
ils ont gagné non et tu sais ce que moi
quand il suit le match de grande des
grosses équipes
j'attends rien et il crie pas
il est comme ça des fois devant l'écran
il est hyper concentré quoi
mais il y a une il y a une photo de
de Mazet quand il avait regardé le match
de barrage pour le maintien en
Ligue 1 et Fab il est juste assis comme
ça il est juste comme ça sur son siège
les mains comme ça quoi il regarde le
foot comme ça hyper concentré beaucoup
plus que pour les parties d'échecs
mais ouais bon bah donc du coup tu as
pris une théorie de fab
ah ouais cavalier c'est bientôt
tu te prends du fabibi et en plus c'est
un pot bah oui mais bon on sait qu'il
prépare Ding maintenant oui en fait il
donne pas des cours le soir juste il
parle alding quoi ok amigos une chose de
Claire
ok moi en commentaire c'est sur la
théorie quoi une chose est claire pour
moi que quand
et surtout bien si le fou ne pas sur de
3 mots sur ce 4 parce que dans cette
situation là c'est quoi il appartient
pas à la casse 4
il
doit être
déplacer
nouveauté théorique
non mais t'imagines la qualité du
commentaire quand même
oui en fait ouais on est on est quand
même à la pointe de la théorie je moi je
commence sans toi et quand vous laissez
supprimer
je me demande ce que pense les vendeurs
de guéri dans le chat parce que guéri
devait pas avoir cavalier C6
[Rires]
de MC Solaar tu te rappelles peut-être
les boys band non c'est pas la chanson
mais le titre
[Musique]
ça a été d'aller au moment de
la chanson Caroline
Carlos
alors
paraît-il que
c'était arrivé comme une surprise
pourrait-il que pas que moi mais en fait
tous les recours ne sont pas au courant
de cette théorie là
bon j'aime bien ce que je vois j'aime
bien ce que je vois en fait en fait sur
la route ici j'ai essayé de pronostiquer
pour moi-même qui est-ce qui va nous
arriver aujourd'hui et je me suis dit
que le plus probablement quand même
après le Tempête radio calme aujourd'hui
ce que je me suis dit sur la route ici
sur cette pronostic mais ce que je me
souviens en tout cas ça en prend un
petit peu le chemin
mais est-ce que ça peut être une
stratégie en championnat du monde juste
de changer d'ouverture à chaque avec les
Noirs je veux dire
quoi
1978 le match de carpoque contre
plusieurs ce qu'on donne y compris il y
a comme Murray
et donc il est venu surtout avec les
variantes ouvertes de l'espagnol avec
les Noirs
ont trouvé les moyens donc il a laissé
assez secondaire de pets stopper les
variantes ouvertes et en attendant il a
changé peut-être quatre ou cinq
couvertures avec le noir contre 4 puis
ils ont fait le boulot il est revenu
avec les variantes ouvertes et il a
écrasé dans une très bonne finale mais
il a perdu le match
et donc il a égalisé le score parce que
ça a été 5 doigts à l'espace de 4
parties les réussites de gagner 3 à
partir trois finales parmi les meilleurs
de l'histoire des échecs d'ailleurs pour
que ça intéresse et malheureusement elle
est finalement perdu
terrible terrible horrible d'ailleurs
c'est en quelque sorte
en quelque sorte le noyau dur du
scénario du film sur les
échecseriser
en 1983 3 les diagonales
coopération franco-allemand non
avec Michel Piccoli
toujours côté
Yann et il est pas bien
sur l'échiquier surtout Yann qui le fait
pas souvent ça veut dire beaucoup de
bêtises
et en plus c'est juste le principal de
l'ordi en général je considère c'est
discutable moi je considère si vous
jouez pas contre les Français ni eux
sans contrôle
ce que vous avez un trou de le
répertoire
un trou de trop il a joué mais bon là ok
c'est avantage noir déjà là c'est
théorie de fabibi maintenant
virgule
il change la vie
non mais je pense que ça va vraiment
être facile comme parti pour dire
bon ce que je vois comment
j'ai pas baissé petit rock c'est de
mettre la dame sur ce set
et pousser ce son
et puis c'est décidé quoi faire avec le
cavalier de 5 soit lui garder joue sur
deux cinq soit le déplacer
n'importe quel coup oui et je sais pas
quoi c'est ça et donc depuis un truc
comme tour à de 8 et puis voir ce que
l'adversaire va faire non mais là ça a
vraiment tout dépend de ce que
l'adversaire là ça a l'air tranquille
pour les Noirs juste pas se prendre un
truc comme ça
mais bon normalement enfin faut juste
contrôler que ça fasse ça
d'ailleurs parlant du cavalier de 5 il
est cool pour limiter le faux sang comme
ça e3f4 non G5 l'échange de fou va
gravement affaiblir les cases 4 donc et
c'est vrai que c'est une case mais c'est
une case
hyper modeste et B3
avec le covalier sur 2,5 si tu avais le
temps de mettre le fond B2 ça peut aller
mais là tu auras pas le temps donc un
gros bon cavalier quoi
il bouffe
je pense que les prochains coups c'est
rock rock tout relent vraiment dame C7
vous baisser je pense que les coups
qu'on vient de montrer ils sont trop
mais en fait l'équipe ruskov
va voir quelques problèmes en fait tu
sais parce que si tu joues que tu joues
que les deux mois
par contre apprendre pendant le mois de
septembre c'est très dur surtout quand
tu connais pas qui est le système il va
choisir parce que dingue française
depuis très longtemps et puis il y en a
beaucoup des systèmes et il y a vraiment
beaucoup et donc un de ces même pas
le mignon et il y a beaucoup de nouveaux
je peux vous dire si pur chien pour
l'équipe parce que comme ça ok on fait
quoi cinq au collège sans qu'on
connaitre ok E5 mais après E5 rien qui
est en mode Cannes 5 il y a 6 grandes
lignes quoi et en plus là où il va pas
avoir de bol c'est que il a il va y
avoir un jour de repos après parce qu'il
faut bien se reposer demain
on s'est reposé hier donc on doit
resoufler demain mais je veux dire par
là qu'il aura pas de jours de repos
entre les blancs et les noirs
et après les blancs sont genre de repos
au milieu
[Musique]
ce qui peut avoir son importance
ah ouais la seule faute c'était de ne
pas commencer avec les Françaises plutôt
dans les parties pressantes ouais mais
bon c'est pas grave déjà il a changé au
bon moment ok danse 7 presque sur
presque sur toute manière la dame
appartient dans cette case il y a pas de
meilleures cases ici pour la dame noire
donc dans ce 7 je suppose sans trop
réfléchir
vous foutez
j'ai l'impression que dans tous les cas
tu vas jouer regarde l'ordi dans tout ce
qu'il dit c'est fou baisser dame c'est 7
et 2 prochains coups dans un ordre dans
l'autre je pense que ça change rien en
vrai
logique ma maman
7 tu peux te dire que le fou il y a un
ouais mais bon enfin ça va jamais
arriver en vrai
juste une question de débiles le plus
probablement
donc
plutôt que
cette dame 5
sûrement pas trop mignon
je peux me frotter que théoriquement
j'ai réussi de crier quelques faiblesses
pour les finales c'est pas sûr que ce
soit si faible en fait le problème je
comprends mais au moins jeunes
ici je refais dedans
ouais mais enfin
quoi
c'est pas sûr que tu es un rêve quoi que
si je réussis à faire F6 ce 5 a fait moi
aussi j'ai un rêve en fait j'ai pas peur
de fier
mais j'ai peur que tes deux pions vont
bien bloquer mes trois ça c'est vrai on
est bloqué en fait c'est sûr ça c'est
c'est la théorie en fait
mais tu veux dire que ce truc de ces
deux pions qui bloque ces trois là c'est
pas très connu
oui mais parce que parfois oui parfois
ça devient faible laisse-moi moi montrer
le début de cette partie gauche
C4
C5 E5 que les J8 D4 maintenant ça se
joue plus de 4 CD dame de 4 cavaliers
un truc comme ça non non non non
pas tout à fait comme ça mais les
structures de
structures est devenu comme ça
donc et il a gagné une partie
remarquable dans le final dans les
femelles pas tout à fait pareil quand
même non bien sûr déjà le pion n'est pas
sur ce dos mais sur ce cadre énormément
de choses
ça change vraiment beaucoup de choses
dans
qui réfléchit la raison
de toute manière tu vois le faire
pourquoi perdre du temps d'autres façons
impossible de comprendre les différences
entre vous deux
et surtout en profondeur 39 c'est déjà
00 ah oui c'est juste que comme je suis
pourri j'aime pas qu'il
dépense du temps pour rien juste
c'est pas la peine c'est sûrement de
comprendre c'est quoi les différences en
fait
[Rires]
[Musique]
mettre ta tour ici ou enfin en C8 ou en
D8 à voir comment tu les places et jouer
c'est 5 ou jouer c'est ça attends
[Musique]
devenir meilleur bien sûr mais pour cela
de toute manière je suis obligé de
les trois
mais on va voir
on va voir ce qui joue Ding en tout cas
[Musique]
c'est trois peut-être vous bossette sur
faute de 3 à chaque fois il faut
considérer que le F4 donc plutôt non
alors
je pense que je suis microscopique ma
meilleure déjà et tout sur de
vraiment
mais moi je sais pas je contesterai déjà
plus rien avec les Blancs j'aurais
dégoûté de mon ouverture non mais
vraiment ça me dégoûte de voir ça
arriver ça me dégoûte vraiment
bah ça confirme une règle avant
d'enté le match c'est pas qu'il faut
préparer les les ouvertures habituelles
de l'adversaire mais vaut mieux aussi
découvrir tes faiblesses et dans le cas
de dépôt qu'on me joue toujours que au
lieu de 2 et il fonce pour se
positionner
un peu considéré les françaises comme un
trou
c'est c'est une très bonne décision de
l'équipe de Ding
et d'ailleurs d'ailleurs parlant de
rapport à chaque fois on parle de lui
que plutôt comme Ding a joué avec le bon
rapport est en grand joueur de la
française elle n'a jamais été un grand
joueur de dimanche
et en plus nepo c'est plutôt un bon
joueur d'antimarchal avec les Blancs
ouais sans aucun doute contrairement à
ce que
c'est juste que il est bon de Commandeur
d'un petit Marshall mais
personne n'est sûrement le meilleur
joueur des Espagnols classiques de tout
le temps avant ça a été contesté
peut-être entre car pauvre kasparo fait
j'avoue
la structure de carlsback et les
Espagnols classiques
ça va être toujours le plus grand
classique éternellement
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que tu penses que ça va donner
d'ailleurs aux grandes chaises tours
parce qu'au grandes chaise tour là début
mai il y a une époque qui joue il y a
ding dyrène qui joue ya Richard rapport
qui joue est-ce que tu penses qu'ils
vont réussir à jouer correctement parce
que ça commence déjà le 5 mai genre 4
jours après le match championnat du
monde où tu penses que c'est impossible
d'enchaîner avec ça dépend de l'issue du
match
parfois d'ailleurs ça dépend même pas de
l'issue du match parfois
enfin ça change c'est parfois le joueur
complètement épuisé après parfois il est
sur les ailes quoi je me rappelle par
exemple les cours n'était pas trop bien
pour gagner les tournois où il y a des
fois et pas trop fort le meilleur
exemple de ce type de tournoi seiche
cancer oui il y a des mecs
pas top top il y a des joueurs de lutte
et une seule fois que il a gagné c'était
après le match de Bruxelles
c'était quelque chose comme un ou deux
mois après non peut-être deux mois cette
jeune heure de moi mais là c'est 4 jours
après c'est quand même pas pareil
j'arrive juste pas à comprendre que dans
quel état tu peux arriver après avoir
entamé 14 parties de championnats du
monde
citer les coups et partir
on est d'accord dans un dans un état
dans automaton je peux pas dire mieux
d'accord que leur niveau va être
normalement
ah non ils vont pas briller normalement
elles seront juste là
le principe de Pierre de Coubertin et
ils vont juste participer c'est c'est la
spécificité des temps à d'échec où c'est
très bizarre de faire un match du
championnat du monde tu as rien fait
pendant 8 mois c'est tout d'un coup
après le match champion du monde tu as
un gros tournoi entre guillemets enfin
et au top proclamé gros tournois offline
c'est juste le début du grand chastour
mais j'ai été étonné quand tu vois que
ok une époque digne rapporte enfin ça me
paraît tellement impossible tu finis ce
match elles ont signé à la maison
donc ils vont prendre un Bobby quoi mais
je veux dire par là que pour le tournoi
c'est tellement incohérent comme
calendrier parce que ça paraît enfin
juste tu finis le match tu prends un
avion tu vas jouer un autre tournoi
ça paraît juste impossible mentalement
physiquement je sais pas c'est comme si
tu viens de finir le tour de France et
deux jours après tu vas faire le Tour
d'Espagne et c'est ça je me rappelle
je pense que j'ai entamé le tournoi
rapide le fameux en Corse à Bastia je me
rappelle que j'ai eu le sentiment que
comment comment décrire mon sentiment
[Musique]
enfin j'étais j'étais
non je sais pas comment décrire on nous
dit ça fait une belle pub pour le temps
d'accueillir les deux candidats non mais
c'est pas une question de pub je sais
pas c'est comme si tu fais la finale de
la Coupe du Monde et trois jours après
tu vas jouer un quart de finale de Ligue
des Champions enfin c'est pas de la pub
c'est juste c'est juste être bête enfin
je sais pas comment dire ça s'appelle
pas de la pub quoi
c'est juste impossible en fait
d'écrire mon état à l'époque c'était
comme j'ai pris la nuit 3 somnifères
j'imagine c'est un peu un jouable en
fait ça paraît impossible
fit desk les indices
[Musique]
bah écoutez il y a plusieurs
organisations y compris bien sûr ces
organisations là ne cherchent pas
rendre le calendrier cohérent ah non
c'est c'est vraiment très très
incohérent
après tant mieux pour les autres parce
qu'il y aura l'IRISA et Maxime qui
joueront aussi donc il y a des points à
aller chercher évidemment bah pour une
fois depuis longtemps mais on va
finalement voir les réseaux un jour mais
il va beaucoup jouer là parce qu'il va
jouer le grand chest tour il va jouer
après le Nord wechat
il a un calendrier assez chargé
on nous dit les dates du grand chasseur
ont été annoncé avant les dates du match
de Coupe du Monde ouais mais je sais pas
tu as des sports par exemple le tennis
au hasard c'est bizarre mais d'année en
année ils réussissent à avoir un
calendrier qui marchait les trois ça
marche pas dessus bah c'est pas c'est
pas une excuse bah du coup tu as une
fédération internationale qui s'occupe
pas de 20 tu peux prendre le problème
comme tu veux mais dans ça paraît d'une
incohérence flagrante mais après il y a
peut-être que ça paraît normal pour les
autres elle les raisins n'a presque pas
joué depuis un an si je me trompe pas ça
me rappelle que
après le tournoi
international en Tunisie que il n'a pas
terminé je parle de Bobby Fischer
le tournoi un point milieu comme il
était en tête il n'a pas joué pendant 3
ans et demi je pense il est retournait 3
ans de Demi et ça a été tout à fait à
notre joueur il s'est René en fait et
puis il a brillamment à gagner le
tournoi international et les brillage de
jouer au match du siècle donc URSS
contre le reste du monde il a écrasé
deux adversaires dans les matchs de
candidats 6-060 et ça ça joue jamais
répété de l'histoire des échecs puis il
a écrasé ex champion du monde pétrochoc
et puis pourquoi je tousse ce sujet pour
les finales
il est venu encore complètement
différent complètement différent il a
entamé les ouvertures qu'il n'a jamais
joué il est ouvert
toutes les nouvelles pages dans la
théorie des échecs si vous voulez ça a
été le combat que le plus
légendaire de toute l'histoire des
échecs je pense que pour toujours après
c'était une autre époque
ça a été un autre époque mais
plusieurs choses que le serti en ce
moment-là ils ont surpassé son temps de
vendre 25 ans
plus tard quand on se passe qui pour son
match en Serbie à un moment donné il a
joué une système contre le variante
contre le système Brière et l'espagnol
je me suis dit mais c'est quoi ce
système en fait je comprenais pas il est
vrai il a gagné brillamment mais je
comprenais pas c'est quoi ce système
c'est en fait la profondeur du système
j'ai compris que il y a quelques-uns
avec l'aide d'ordinateurs donc si tu
veux genre 25 ans plus tard j'ai compris
les profondeurs du truc ah mais le gars
était profond non c'est cher
tu penses j'ai l'impression qu'il envoie
moins qui avant
moi je pense qu'il y a c'est beaucoup de
nouvelles idées encore pour moi mais
j'ai encore quelques-unes dans mes
stocks en fait même moi
[Musique]
donc si si c'est toujours possible de
trouver de nouvelles odeurs mais t'avais
pas le cavalier C6
[Musique]
il a fait un mouvement il a joué j'ai eu
l'impression qu'il jouait mais des fois
tu as l'impression qu'il joue et il joue
pas bah elle est tellement énervé que
oui
il retourne aller chercher le type
mais c'est bizarre il réfléchisse aussi
enfin il a raison après de rentrer dans
sa partie de réfléchir mais là il
réfléchit très très longtemps ok par
contre au niveau du temps c'est presque
égale nos 40 presque d'or pour mais pour
une heure 36 pour Ding comme tu dis il
essaie de rendre bien de rentrer dans la
partie
quand tu as une nouveauté comme ça il
faut il faut prendre le temps et bien
bien s'imprégner de la position plutôt
de s'entendait pas à ce ce temps
j'ai égalisé très facilement dans
l'ouverture après 8 9 coups sans aucun
effort et qui a été étonné en match
championnat du monde que ce soit si
simple et peut-être qu'il se dit bon bah
pourquoi pas jouer le gain déjà quoi
pas juste essayer de gagner quoi non
mais c'est vrai que parfois
tu te prépares contre quelqu'un et il y
a une variante critique et touche tu
cherches tu cherches tu cherches puis
juste avant les parties tu te dis pas ok
mais à quoi ça sert je joue un autre
truc puis tu sors un autre truc et tu es
tellement bien après 2 minutes du jour
que tu te dis mais à quoi ça sert ce
analyses et tout bah vas-y juste
ok d'ailleurs je pense que toi tu avais
commencé plus tôt avec football
je sais pas moi j'aurais voulu garder
une flexibilité avec la
tempête
il empêche fou je sens où peut-être
c'est pas que la casse cette curry quand
c'est dire pour cette dame peut-être
ouais
je suppose que eventuellement parlant
peut être embaucher c'est possible aussi
je sais pas je peux commencer par c'est
5 je peux encore me donner le temps de
réfléchir ouais d'ailleurs après ce 5 tu
menaces
les défauts de trois fois quatre
on peut montrer
un bon avantage parce que faut 4 dames
la tour est bien défendu
non mais tu prépares c'est 5 et tu te
gardes tu te gardes le choix de la dame
et sur un coup comme B3 on va faire fouf
6 proposé par le chat et surtout B1
pardon cavalier C3 fourchette
j'aime vraiment la position des Noirs
moi je pense que si tu me donnais le
choix ça se peut que je préfère jouer
avec cette position là où cette position
là précisément je joue pas avec les
Blancs normalement tout simplement parce
que je sais pas que où est-ce que mon
rêve sauf échanger les dents un beau
jour mais quand est-ce que ça va arriver
comment est-ce que ça va arriver parce
que normalement ici ça va être très dur
de changer les dents non si tu me donnes
les blancs je joue déjà pour nul en fait
tu peux pas
sauf les cavaliers toutes les pièces
sont là
ça veut dire que tu bouges les pieds et
puis en regardant ce que je veux faire
tu vois pour faire ça
c'est ce que je dis ouais je vais jouer
pour faire nul
après 10 coups avec les Blancs
en match Championnat du Monde bah qui
qui rigole
je le vois je le vois qui vient se
placer il rigole peut-être ressemble ton
pessimisme pour les bons
il va pas être bien tu penses qu'il
pense que les blancs sont mieux bah qui
tu penses qu'il préfère les blancs
non quand même pas
mais c'est peut-être la malédiction de
baquis ça peut-être être la première
partie où il se passe vraiment rien quoi
ça peut non aujourd'hui ça peut faire ça
éventuellement oui bah déjà je pense que
ils ont quand même dépensé trop de
cellules nerviques
au cours des derniers parties frappe
contre frappe frappe contre frappe
normalement il est vrai que l'organisme
humain veut se calmer après tant de
l'action donc
c'est ce qui serait pas mal j'aurais
donné 70% pour les every les événements
plutôt calmes aujourd'hui en fait qui
serait pas mal c'est qu'il fasse ça
aujourd'hui
prochaine partie d'ingale et blanc ça
joue parce qu'on a récupéré nerveusement
puis une épaule et noire de nouveau
l'épaule est blanc de nouveau on se
calme parce que système nerveux et elle
est trop en ébullition et comme ça
pendant tout le match Ding les blancs on
joue n'est pas les blancs nuls
et à un moment donné d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui
ça devient important donc en a prévu au
développement plutôt calme aujourd'hui
mais si c'est le cas bon il le voit il
restait trois blancs contre 4 blancs
contre trois noirs on a vu dans ce match
que c'était loin d'être anecdotique de
commencer avec les Blancs
ici le service ça joue mesdames et
messieurs on va laisser Étienne me
remplacer quand même l'homme que l'on
veut voir ouais mais je te vois tu es
prêt tu es prêt
je vais te mettre les deux
j'arrive au mauvais moment hein c'est
pas la meilleure maman pas la meilleure
mais j'ai l'impression que Ding c'est
plutôt Ding qui a envie de jouer pour
gagner aujourd'hui
non parce que moi j'ai joué cette
ouverture il y a pas longtemps contre
comment il s'appelle championnat
d'Europe et sur cavalier des deux Mons
c'est nul assez facilement quand on joue
pas cavalier F6 mais cavaliers C6 ce que
l'on a dit et donc je me demande est-ce
qu'il a pas préparé Cavaliere 6 pour
essayer de jouer un petit peu après
c'est pas mieux pour les Noirs mais ok
il va le centre quand même enfin c'est
il cherche un combat en fait
je me demande ce que d'ailleurs vient de
gagner
pourquoi pas essayer de tomber à celui
qui est un peu instable
aujourd'hui parce que
toujours
la française donc je sais que l'avance
ou le ou trois cavaliers C3 c'est quand
même beaucoup plus
dangereux surtout pour quelqu'un qui
joue pas la française avec les Noirs
c'est un peu c'est comme si tu jouais
contre une carroca nous enfin il est
déjà plus dans ces sites système Ding
une variante d'avance tu vois il a pas
-3 cavaliers C3 c'est ça serait moins
dans ses habitudes d'ailleurs tu penses
après trois cavaliers c'est trop et le
réthoisi
B4
par contre par contre mais pour le même
jour que vous réussissent dernièrement
les dernières fois que les jouets les
Françaises les joueurs donc peut-être
alors mais je pense qu'il s'y attendait
pas vraiment à moins alors à moins parce
que j'ai mis les turbines à moins qui
est-ce qu'on peut revenir un peu j'ai la
main sur la souris
[Musique]
je me demandais parce que j'ai mis un
peu l'ordi est-ce que ça serait pas ici
qui voulait peut-être vous ces quatre
non il a eu plusieurs parties contre
Sacha que
ça donne vraiment rien j'ai vu qu'il
avait toujours eu mais c'est des parties
internet
c'est pas des parties enfin c'est des
parties sur Internet
c'est tout je crois
mais non mais là ok il a après qu'il va
lui prendre ses 6 il est absolument rien
ici
je pense qu'il s'attendait juste pas du
tout à la française bien sûr qui est un
peu bizarre parce que il met une telle
pression à Digne depuis tellement
d'années sur l'espagnol
quand à Richard qui arrive en face je
sais pas moi
dans ces cas-là dans ces cas-là c'est
plutôt
dommage enfin pour moi et plutôt bizarre
que Ding n'a pas commencé de jouer les
Françaises un peu avant il aurait pu
pour pour plus mais bon finalement ça
surprend quand même regarde il fait fout
des trois et quoi après
8 c'est 5 OK dans ce sac tu fais
automatiquement
dame alors
parce que peut-être les Noirs vont pas
trop peur vont pas avoir trop de peur de
fourchette
c'est pas moi j'ai envie de cavalier
5 H 6
parce qu'il y a pas trop normalement ici
ça dépend de son H6 en fait oui bien sûr
il faut calculer ça
ok mais bien sûr j'ai pas vu
ok j'ai pas vu
j'ai parce que ces quatre touches tout
de suite donc est-ce qu'avec fou des
trois il a peut-être envie de ça déjà
peut-être qu'il est cette forcer les
choses avec des trois dame c'est
cette dame 4 et tu dis peut-être G6 ici
mais
oui
[Musique]
je veux aussi 5 que je veux menacer
c'est vrai que c'est une bonne case de
développement donc on va jouer 6 on
imagine Tour Eiffel 8 tout rêve D8 ici
alors on sait jamais trop mettre la tour
parce qu'elle peut être bien huit avec
la tour à 8 en D8
mais bon c'est quand même tellement
logique d'aller directement sur la
colonne tu auras des 8
ouais on menace ces 5
l'échange d'État ici c'est un peu c'est
bien pour le noir probablement après
demain
si il cherche la bagarre il peut il peut
avoir parce que alors on nous demande si
je cherche la bagarre il peut jouer G6
ouais tout à fait raison
[Musique]
alors que si oui s'il laisse le
sacrifice ça va être nul alors pourquoi
dame C7 c'est si logique en fait la ici
il a pas joué encore fou d'être
pourquoi c'est si logique parce que
il faut déjà on veut mettre une tour sur
la colonne D et en défendre le fou
défend le fou oui c'est vrai
[Musique]
c'est la case de la dame on va pas la
mettre en B6 on va pas ouais non non il
y a pas de cases en fait et aussi parce
qu'on commence de menacer éventuellement
4 dans 4 et 6 oh ouais mais ici on a la
case il y a déjà la caisse de 5 qui est
un peu plus faible mais il y a les C4
simplement comme tu dis le fou peut-être
d'abord faut acheter ça
[Musique]
en l'air pas clair peut-être
tu vois le fou il est en l'air ici tu as
raison donc si il est obligé de faire
une cavalier on va
[Musique]
donc oui bon là il réfléchit c'est
normal il prend son temps mais il va
jouer dame C7 je vois pas vraiment
d'autres coups peut-être cavalier F6
c'est un autre coup d'ailleurs
moi c'était moi dommage
7 et cavalie F6 c'est quand même un coup
parce que à part de fou je sens que les
amis elle est bon auront l'option de
mettre le feu sur F4
c'est aussi profilactique contre
les deux il va c'est un peu de temps là
sur le coup dame c'est ça
et maintenant donc ne peut faire un
petit check dans le cadre en gros
actif en gros c'est un check si le
adversaire veut faire nul parce que
comme on a montré que
peut-être que calculait ça oui un peu 4
d'ailleurs pourquoi pas parce qu'il sait
qu'il est tranquille là il sait qu'il
est très tranquille
je vois pas d'autres cools le fou des
deux on a pas trop de cases là pour le
fou des deux pas trop d'aider surtout
pas trop d'idées normalement c'est quand
on a ça on veut plutôt B3 fou B2
parce que regarder là en fait le fou B7
tape sur le roi et vraiment au mieux par
exemple si on arrive à jouer ces cinq
foot D6 on va voir les deux fous qui
tapent sur le roi et souvent dans ces
structures le foot des trois là il est
bien placé mais le poussin il serait
beaucoup mieux en B2 ah oui pour les
notons pour le spectateurs qui ont le
plus souvent les blancs ne sont pas trop
chaudes G3 défendre dans les cases F4
parce que les grandes
oui ça peut se réfléchir mais là ça perd
beaucoup de temps j'ai presque même que
l'impression rien que prise et H6 non
là c'est beaucoup de temps la case F4 et
là c'est le fou qui devient fort non qui
est valide
ça peut être que mieux pour les Noirs
ici donc faut G5 non c'est pas bête mais
ça perd trop de temps et fou des deux on
a pas trop envie parce que ça perd aussi
du temps et ça met les deux fous sur la
colonne des qui va être la seule colonne
ouverte alors après ici je sais pas si
d'abord c'est 5 ou 3 d'abord c'est 5 ça
menace un peu cavalier F4 pour prendre
la paire de fou on n'a pas de cavalier
F4 directement à cause de damocad bien
sûr donc là on peut avoir des cavaliers
F4 dès cavaliers B4 des tu auras des 8
complexe complexe pour les blancs
donc je pense qu'il va jouer damocrate
je suis d'accord je pense qu'il va jouer
dans ma 4
C4 ouais ça pose une question cavalier
sauf qu'on est assez content d'aller en
F6 C4 c'est un coup aussi mais bon
cavalier F6 ou cavalier b46 je dirais si
on peut jouer C5 derrière
oui d'ailleurs il y a pas cavalier dame
[Musique]
4 un truc comme ça je suppose dans ce
cas là
pardon j'ai complètement oublié oui donc
en fait cavalier F4 c'est déjà quasiment
une menace
quoi qu'avec le pion C2 peut-être fou
prendre un profond
pourtant je suis toujours pas sûr que ça
donc quoi que ce soit en fait non mais
c'est pas mieux pour les blancs mais
est-ce que ça égalise en fait je pense
que ça égalise plus par exemple on peut
imaginer un tour 1 en fait je suis pas
sûr de jouer cavalier F4 à cause de
prise prise et ici même fois 6 ouais
ouais ça calme déjà
vaut mieux de combiner les idées de avec
développer les pièces il veut développer
si jamais sur fois 6 fois 8 les amis
ouais alors là de l'épo il est pas sur
l'échiquier mais je pense que ouais je
pense qu'il doit se reconcentrer un peu
parce qu'il voit bien que c'est mal pas
enfin qu'elle est mal engagée cette
partie s'attendait pas à ça
effacer les parties mais il s'est dit
peut-être il faut pas que je vois je
m'en fous trop parce que peut-être après
dame 4 l'adversaire vous va pas jouer
quand les fils moi j'ai 6 dans ce cas-là
il aurait dû faire
du fight ici
qui sait qu'il peut y avoir du fight
très intéressant d'ailleurs
qui est l'option va choisir Ding plutôt
news ou plutôt donc très intéressant
psychologiquement pardon je redis ici il
voit après damocrate en comprenant que
il va jouer aussi
ce n'est pas une solution facile il
prend des risques enfin il joue vraiment
les ouvertures de Richard et ça lui
change tout en fait
il va mieux
d'engager Richard pour ça parce que
quand même je toujours pensé que vos
millions de prendre pas quelqu'un qui
était ressemble au niveau de ton style
mais bien ton antithèse c'est toujours
Millau ça donne toujours une nouvelle
dimension
ouais bah c'est clairement
complémentaire
pour son style c'est vrai qu'un joueur
comme yoyo yangi joue un peu comme Ding
mais au moins il y a je pense un seul
truc qui leur
fait se reprocher l'un de l'autre aux
échecs c'est que rapporte malgré plein
de fantaisistes
malgré tout il aime aussi que même le
fou sur je dors avec le bon
toi aussi tu aimes bien le fond
mais
il est finalement sur l'échiquier ou pas
je vois pas non non c'est bizarre quand
même parce que sa faute je pense je
pense plus que 5 minutes de minutes déjà
que les poids sur l'échiquier un peu
très bien c'est la première fois dans le
dans le match où il est c'est la
première fois au monde que je vois en
images pour le Coran ou un joueur tant
que sa peinture qui marche
n'est pas sur l'échiquier pendant six ou
longtemps ouais mais là c'est pas de la
même je pense que c'est pas la même
chose que dire
je pense qu'il a pris un coup au moral
avec cette ouverture
non mais comme je dis et surtout c'est
c'est ils ont l'échiquier donc il a vu
au pire il est au pire il voit il a vu
le coup adverse
surtout cette dépressive de penser au
travail qui attend toi et ton équipe
pour les prochaines parties avec les
bancs
[Musique]
il voit pas jouer sans que c'est sûr
c'est un petit peu surprenant quand même
de jouer la française Yann qui l'a joué
quand même lui-même qui avait
dans son équipe qui est aussi top joueur
de français c'est risqué de lui envoyer
une française d'un côté oui de l'autre
côté les Français et les grandes
et les grandes
pas mal de foot
avec ce cadre d'emboutissants 4
plusieurs fois de 7 avec
Richard lui-même il est toujours très
mal quoi sur la française d'avance par
exemple même sur la française en général
c'est pour ça que le cavalier des deux
là je suis vraiment
moi je travaillais tellement beaucoup
les Françaises pour mes élèves j'adore
cette ouverture
c'est l'odeur avait raison c'est Les
Mureaux ouais mais de jouer ça pour la
première fois au championnat du monde
c'est dur c'est comme tu vois Yann qui
joue la carte
je pense que quand
j'en suis sûrement il faut checker bien
sûr mais je pense que je veux
une française mais avec les Blancs un
épaules avec les noirs
ok il revient il revient peut-être qu'il
est dit
il a pas réfléchi c'est juste je pense
qu'il s'est juste
psychologiquement ah ouais ouais c'est
bien ça
c'est bien en fait il sait bien que s'il
fait un encore un coup à côté il va
souffrir toute la partie
et il est malin sur ces moments là il
comprend les moments
non je pense que il est complètement
clair ce qu'il veut maintenant c'est
juste il sait pas comment elle va
réussir si l'autre lui permet pas
parlons de dame
je pense qu'il veut partir aujourd'hui
là je vois pas comment tu peux jouer
l'avantage avec les Blancs
d'ailleurs n'oublie pas qu'avoler
pour dans cette partie où se cadre je
vais dire ça a été prévu parce que quand
les Cécile ça a été joué de tempo
mais bon ça se voit sur sur une émission
j'ai mis des positions sur l'ordi ça se
voit que
ce travail
mais c'est travailler pour pour chercher
pour pousser
pour pousser espérons espérons espérons
en tant que le spectateur moi je
l'espère en tant que le supporter de
le spectateurs le mieux c'est nul là
quand même de voir cette torture avec le
noir depuis le début du match j'ai même
j'aimerais bien nouveau voir en train de
pousser avec le noir
déjà moi je suis fan des Espagnols donc
j'aurais préféré j'aurais préféré encore
une espagnole où il pousse avec les
blancs en vrai ça me fait plaisir ça
c'est vraiment son point fort il en a
gagné combien contre digne des Espagnols
avec des trois des ou comme la cinquième
je suis pas sûr sur xoslo je pense
qu'après dame 4 ça va faire G6 ici
d'ailleurs est-ce que
est-ce que dame
e46 parce que j'ai une autre question
mais c'est vrai que
une autre raison peut-être pour que tu
peux jouer
F4
ouais disons pour le spectateurs
on fait on casse la structure pas de
problème
on regagne un pion et on finit par par
un tour C8 et d'un procès de
probablement nul quand même
donc plutôt fou je sens mais ici
maintenant que la dame elle est décalée
elle est sur une moins bonne case
avec des idées cavaliers décès des fois
donc tu as raison que sur damocat en
fait c'est G6 en fait une question si je
veux absolument échanger les dents juste
je veux dans le cadre
donc ici il peut choisir en tout rêve D8
et Tour Eiffel 8 et pourquoi tu veux
absolument échanger les dames non je
veux pas c'est juste pour les
spectateurs le problème c'est que c'est
pas trop bien je suppose parce que faute
6 sur F1 que 4 et il y a pas de plus
haute que les fautes c'est plutôt pour
le spectateur parce que depuis tout à
l'heure avec qui on a parlé et si il est
beau en doivent changer les dents au
viol les changer les dents je suppose
que normalement oui mais c'est dur de
réaliser le problème c'est qu'on va
perdre des tempos en échangeant les
dames c'est vrai c'est ça le problème
c'est vrai que si la tu retires les
dames directement de l'échiquier et très
haut blanc ok je pense que on est
content mais
[Musique]
mais on peut pas tout on peut pas tout
simplement
ça a été il y a eu un coup là
alors là parce que techniquement moi je
suis pas je suis pas Kevin
il a joué dame
peut-être en intérimaire au premier
moment critique en fait
parce que le coup proche le prochain
coup de noir va montrer va bien dévoiler
les intentions du Ding je cherche plutôt
alors peut-être pas encore ouais mais
peut-être pas encore parce que après
c'est sûr qu'après ça je sais pas si on
l'échiquier je suis pas
[Musique]
j'ai pas trop envie de laisser en fait
au final
je te comprends
bien joué de l'autre côté après J6 la
dame sera forcé de se cassettes
ça ça va arriver
ici là il va être un corner encore ici
ok ce que moi peut-être c'est tour FEA
en préparant les cases E5 pour le cheval
Tour Eiffel
et c'est bizarre parce qu'on joue pas
sur la colonne ouverte on joue pas tout
radin qui pour un peu tout le monde ça
pourrait être un peu plus simple mais
ouais tour E1 c'est un coup habituel
dans les Françaises de la Casa on joue
pour cette case c'est 5 disons
je veux toucher F7
d'un F4 ouais et puis ça c'est des
genres de
tactique qui qui sont importantes
ok ça peut être que mieux pour les
blancs maintenant
avec cette tactique donc je suppose pas
que
le cheval se ressemble
quand même
et là bon
OK
compliqué comme position c'est vrai
qu'il laisse le fou H6 donc il réfléchit
à ça là on va pas aller trop loin on
attend on va attendre les coups c'est
comme comme en partie on peut jamais
aller trop trop loin non plus
je pense que c'est plus ou moins ce
qu'on va voir en fait
plus ou moins c'est bien la suite de la
partie
non on nous dit que G6 ça semble ma
meilleure coupe cavalier FC je sais pas
moi j'aime bien cavalier en général ok
c'est vraiment parce qu'ici il y a fu F4
en fait c'est sinon on est content on
ouvre le four on a fait plie pas trop
les pièces encore on va voir
G6 on a fait oublie quand même les cases
noires même si
[Musique]
après j'ai 6 on affaiblit les cases
noires
ouais c'est hyper hyper pénible DF5 on
n'a jamais le pion ici c'est aussi pour
ça qu'on joue souvent les Tour Eiffel
les Noirs
là les Noirs ils ont un avantage de dans
le centre donc s'ils arrivent à jouer au
5 F5 ils sont toujours contents mais on
y arrive jamais parce que comme Vlady la
case de 5 elle est blindée par 3 qui va
le F3
les blancs vieux la voir
[Musique]
je mets des je mets des couleurs de
partout mais c'est pas fait exprès là je
suis pas bien
les finales de championnats du monde ça
fait longtemps que c'est sous forme de
match après il y a les Coupes du Monde
la Coupe du Monde un moment elles ont
désigné les champions du monde mais ils
sont revenus à la forme match qui est
quand même mieux pour en Championnat du
Monde
avoir maintenant il y a une coupe du
monde et un championnat du monde c'est
quand même le mieux
je clique totalement au hasard ouais
alors cavalier
malgré ce qu'on a dit avant donc si vous
voulez un petit surprise
dans mon cas
et les questions alors après ces cinq
fruits F4 qu'est-ce que il est préparé
ces cinq forcés parce que G6 on se met
dans dans les cases noires là soit fou
j'ai 5 ou F4
donc G6 pas possible H6 on se met sur le
sacrifice
parce que maintenant on a le fou en B7
qui est qui est bloqué par le pion on a
pu le C4 qui tape le feu n'a pas réussi
de toucher le four sur deux trois il est
content
il voit quelque chose Ding il veut il
veut offrir quelque chose ouais bien sûr
peut-être aller
oui je sais pas s'il y a des raisons
pour
ouais mais alors il a pas beaucoup
réfléchi quand même parce que
franchement moi ça me fait ça me fait
peur le fouet 4
ça me fait peur le ça me ferait ouais
ouais il comprend pas là il envoie d'un
match 4
ça va être fou F4 à tempo en fait
il est surpris il est très content
il est très content alors regardons un
petit peu ce C5 fouet 4 qu'est-ce qui
peut jouer alors si je joue fous des 6
il y a fougère
on a un gros problème sur HC bon je vais
pas regarder les autres Kung Fu pour F3
parce que bon c'est
il faut bouger la dame on a quoi on a
dames C6 non
parce que
à cette fois
au pire c'est juste ça il y a peut-être
faux-5 mais ça c'est un pion déjà on a
pu le fou prend F3 qu'on a regardé tout
à l'heure
qu'est-ce qu'on a sur fu F4 on a dame B6
c'est le plus logique pour moi
visuellement à part dame B6
elle est rien mais les blancs peuvent
essayer fouger sans Kung Fu E5
là on réfléchit là j'ai quand même la
première chose c'est
[Musique]
maintenant qu'on a le décalé la dame je
sais pas peut-être fou 5 non
est-ce qu'on peut fouer ça
ça me fait peur ça si j'ai les Noirs je
suis pas très bien là
ou sinon il veut donner le pion ah non
non il ne va pas le faire
attention ça c'est pas mal hein
peut-être parce que alors il y a des
idées comme ça qui existent
pour aller en E7 mais ok sur l'échiquier
quand tu as jamais joué la française je
pense que c'est dur à
[Musique]
ça fait peur en tout cas mais c'est une
idée de ton rêve de vie
moi je peux regagner le pion en jouant
fourchette mon autre monde
c'est pas si clair quand même avec les
cases c'est pas c'est quoi par contre la
voix
il y a la dame qui est enfermée là
ça se regarde ça se regarde
[Musique]
aussi ça fait super peur
et je perds par une manière ou l'autre
moi je vois pas comment
[Musique]
ah d'accord
je sais pas ok ça se regarde OK
ça ça se regarde
[Musique]
mais je sais pas s'il veut s'il veut ça
du tout
mais là c'est très bizarre de jouer de
jouer cavalier FC et de réfléchir sur da
bashka parce que vraiment
à moins à moins qu'il peut y réfléchisse
cette histoire
avec la même idée de jouer sur gs5
H6 avec cette idée avec cette idée
m'a bien probable que d'autres
possibilités ça c'est au pire de toute
manière les Noirs risquent rien
ouais donc il a quand même du Tour fd8
mais ça reste la même chose tu aurais V8
c'est comme C5 on a du foie F4
non mais là c'est une vraie erreur non
mais
ok avant-hier il a juste fait une partie
fantastique mais là son coup cavalier F6
avec cette réflexion derrière
c'est pas optimal okay
sur la je menace d'accord tu menaces
cavalier des 5
alors on va juste montrer que tout va
bien le coup on a envie de jouer ça ça
marche pas
parce que faut prendre S7 interne marche
pas à cause de cavalier prend pour
prendre des 8 et il faut prendre H4
facile mais à avoir quand même donc tu
auras des on peut pas à cause de
F3
parce qu'ici bon j'imagine quoi
on a quand même deux menaces
mais là j'imagine que même
peut-être je peux juste dame mais
attention
si je joue dans le
sur Fougères
moi mais attention enfin c'est des ça
c'est regarder je comprends très bien
mais regardons ok alors ça c'est une
option sur dame D8 pardon
c'est que tu vas faire
pas mal Damas 3 j'aime bien
parce que on alors sur un coup comme
cavalier après attends non mais j'ai des
coups comme
j'ai plutôt envie de faire cavalier 5 et
Damas 3 mais dommage 3 c'est un joli
coup aussi
parce que là il y a pas de mais tu peux
peut-être faire H6 menace cavalier des 5
est-ce qu'on est pas sur le même genre
de mais maintenant tu auras des
et cavalier dessin qui allait de quoi
d'accord
quoi
et sur que
pas sûr mais ouais la position elle est
très très contente
intermédiaire donc je fais pas je fais
dame j'ai 4
joli
alors attends on va remonter quand même
parce que on va un peu vite et là il va
réfléchir longtemps donc on peut
regarder des variantes non ça je veux
pas oui je sais que tu veux pas mais on
va montrer quand même au chat pourquoi
Angers 4 parce qu'ici il y a cavalier
chaque intermédiaire fourchette et on
récupère le matos
[Musique]
donc c'est pour ça que Vlad propose ici
dame G4 qui est un très joli coup parce
que maintenant qu'elle va les prendre F4
ici on gagne du matériel on donne une
pièce
tu reprends D8 ça se finit comment là
tout reprend des 8 dame prend F4 et on a
dame cavalier contre deux fous tours
on a l'avantage
donc il y a pas de cavaliers
[Musique]
j'ai cinq peut-être qui peut essayer de
défendre il y a F5
c'est parce que maintenant ah oui
regardez F5 F5 ça c'est un joli coup
parce que dame G6 cavalier prend F4 dame
G3 pareil cavalier preuve 4 et on doit
jouer dame prend cette fois mais comme
il s'est fait une faiblesse peut-être
que c'est intéressant
parce qu'il a quand même aimé maintenant
on arrive avec fousset 4 tours
on peut taper sur les cases blanches
maintenant
donc
ça c'est une option cavalier 5 mais
j'aime bien aussi le coup de Vlad dam H3
on garde H7 sous pression alors là on
est toujours content si je fous pour F3
dans F3 il y a plus hs7 sous pression
mais on prend la paire de fou et là je
peux tuer l'attaque un jeune fou au 4
et surtout radin quand même
au moins je sais pas moi
tout de suite mais
c'est pas obligé de bouffer d'ailleurs
tu peux jouer un truc comme ça
même cavalier
[Musique]
7 il y a des coûts quand même il y a du
développement pour les blancs enfin tu
as quand même jouer dame de 8 à donner
de tempo donc je pense pas qu'il aille
pour ça
mais j'ai une
[Musique]
ouais mais là on est pas sur C5 dames de
8 bon si le joue on va analyser mais tu
sais quoi je pense que les choses qu'on
peut faire
il a loupé 4 il a vu au four
pas facile quand tu changes d'ouverture
comme ça on pourrait dire pour Yann
c'est pareil il avait une sac à se
battre elle était bien elle était
normale
j'ai joué trois Françaises une fois un
blitz deux fois un classique en Bleach
je gagne mais bon et deux fois un
classique à chaque fois à un moment
donné je deviens des millions j'ai senti
que je suis mio mais j'étais pas capable
de
prouver comme quoi c'était clair que je
t'ai mis mais je pouvais pas prouver
juste je veux pas assez désinstinctes
pour cette ouverture là
moi je vois j'ai commencé il y a deux
ans peut-être la française maintenant je
comprends mieux quand même la main elle
bouge plus facilement c'est normal
comme c'est pas des positions que tu as
partout ça c'est un peu comme tu sais
les Caro cadre resserrer que carpe est
tout c'est des trucs tu dois jouer pour
pouvoir jouer des rois au Seds tu as
besoin de l'avoir fait deux trois fois
pour voir que ça marche là
il est pas bien là
mais on voit pas trop d'autres défenses
que c'est 5 fois F4 dame je pense qu'il
va moi je pense qu'il va jouer ça c'est
un joueur actif quand même Ding je pense
qu'il va tenter Dame B6 mais
elle sacrifice que j'ai montré
mais clairement là il est en train de
regarder
[Musique]
donc ton rêve D8 VAD a raison il nous a
dit fou prend H7 cavalier prend H7 dame
prend E7 touche l'option F7 donc on
gagne un peu plus en plus là
bon on va essayer ça tu auras des 8 ce
qui reste on n'a pas très envie mais bon
on a pas trop le choix et ici peut-être
un tour ADN ou Tour Eiffel 1 pour
continuer à mettre la pression ce que je
vois pas trop les par exemple après un
tour Eiffel
je vois pas trop des H6 maintenant ici
c'est clair avec le tour E3 qui va
arriver
[Musique]
enfin ça fait hyper peur là je serais
pas bien là c'est important de noter
peut-être un petit peu remontrer cette
position
alors pardon
[Musique]
peut-être peut-être important de noter
que sur justice il y a toujours des
possibilités comme ah il y a
pratiquement
H7 reste sous pression
complètement dans les positions de dépôt
de recherche pour les petits pots ici
c'est même pas les supposes des
et là alors évidemment Yann il s'est
rendu compte
que de toute façon ça se voyait à sa
tête je vois sur un petit écran là mais
je le vois tout de suite il était en
train de rayonner
et digne qui se dit j'avais choisi entre
la nul facile cavalier F6 ou la partie
compliquée après
si vous arrivez maintenant en fait on
pense que Ding a joué cavalier F6 pour
la variante d'amh4 C5 fou G5
menace il faut prendre FC
H6 vous prend puis on prend d'un prank
et par exemple C4 tape le fou
et ici les blancs sont obligés de
prendre l'échec perpétuel parce que
sinon il se retrouve avec une pièce en
moins tout simplement et on pense en
fait que Ding en jouant cavalier F6 s'il
partait pour cette ligne pour une nulle
rapide alors que il pouvait jouer ici G6
bon qui laisse fresh si ça pas très
envie tu sais quand tu joues pas la
française t'as pas non plus très envie
de donner faux assistant fd8 bon tu dis
et finalement là il a une très bonne
position plutôt même plus facile à jouer
avec les Noirs je dirais
parce qu'une fois qu'on repousse une
fois qu'il repousse les pièces il a le
centre cette décision de jouer que
valive 6 au lieu de G6 me rappelle une
phrase si entre les bagarres et
l'humiliation vous choisissez les
l'obligation vous aurez l'humiliation et
les bagarres
[Musique]
je viens de ça l'histoire du coup comme
elle est ici
non mais après si il pensait que c'était
nul ouais mais ouais bah ça c'est une
erreur tactique il a pris trop facile et
peut-être que le match il tournait trop
bien pour lui il était sur un petit
nuage il a joué peut-être un peu trop
vite son cavalier F6 parce qu'au final
si il pense que cavalie F6 c'est nul
vérifie quoi 10 15 minutes il a joué
vite
il a joué en combien de temps
en train de serrer pendant quelques
heures il fallait manger un petit plat
[Musique]
[Rires]
oui c'est vrai que je voudrais bien je
voudrais pas être à sa place maintenant
tu vas faire nuit le parti et tout de
suite a été le réveil
[Rires]
un chapeau en C5 F4 dame D8 ça c'est les
trucs d'ordinaires on a essayé de
regarder un peu les idées franchement il
le jouera vraiment en dernier ressort
ah c'est pas ce que vous cherchez à
faire
parce que alors encore si C5 webcam D8
donc fu D6 on a dit on se décale et
fougères 5 on a davantage
encore si là on menace directement fou
prend F3 ou qu'il y a des 5 si c'est
très tactique on peut jouer un coup
comme d'habitude mais là c'est pas très
tactique donc en pratique enfin moi je
pense on peut juste pas en fait
c'était intéressant soit alors bon on a
tout radinateur ou pas oui bah si alors
attends c'est noté
cavalier 5 ouais ça c'est terrible je
pense
non
on était sur damage 3 intéressants
parce que cavalier E5 h6 il y a un bon
côté en fait non mais ça comment comment
jouer comme ça
que au moins après le 5
euh
au moins on peut jouer ici c'est sûr
faut jouer sans caméra
non je comprends moi il faut s'en sortir
maintenant il faut faire quelque chose
ouais mais il va jouer de la musique
il va jouer ça dame B6 oui après et tout
fd8 il va il va tenter cette idée je
pense mais je veux pas je sens je veux
jouer
et surtout fd8 ah oui c'est vrai qu'on a
ça ah oui c'est ça qui est terrible
c'est ça le problème
on va le laisser on va le laisser
réfléchir en fait
donnez-moi les blancs ici peut-être
c'est un bon moment pour une petite
pause
parce que maintenant je pense il va
réfléchir encore pendant ce temps là il
va il va planter
le prix le prix
est très grand et on veut pas on veut
pas souffrir à sa place
je sais pas moi j'ai pas de favoris pour
ce match donc
mais malheureusement là il repart sur un
travers de la première et la deuxième
ronde
précision on a l'impression que avec les
Noirs l'un ou l'autre trouve toujours
pas le bon moment pour réfléchir
l'un ou l'autre à un moment donné joue
trop vite il puisse souffre pour le
reste de la partie comme dans les
parties pressendante mais pommiers par
exemple assise que vous voulez de cette
relativement vite c'est devenu nettement
moins bien essayer et puis jusqu'à la
fin de la partie il n'a pas trop bouger
ses pieds donc
l'appareil il a joué
et maintenant donc maintenant tu es
ouais mais les prix des coups en fait
ils sont plus importants que dans une
espagnole par exemple ce qui joue
d'habitude il joue des lignes très
solides même avec les blancs avec les
noirs
et ici quand tu joues françaises ou
quand tu joues tous les prix de chaque
coup c'est encore parce que les
positions
le conflit est plus
et c'est plus des positions à la dépôt
d'ailleurs mais après c'est pas une
question de à la n'est pas ou pas ça
dépend juste parce que la position elle
est bien ou pas normalement ils sont
assez forts pour jouer tous les
meilleurs coups et là je pense que c'est
juste déconcentré en fait un moment
pour
F4 et on va le laisser se tirer les
cheveux un petit peu pendant quelques
minutes et prendre une petite pause et
voir
retourner très vite
tu sais comment mettre on met une pause
on laisse juste comme ça
on attend le boss
qui a joué les meilleurs coups
si c'est pas un bon coup pratique hein
ça c'est sûr
vous voulez faire une pause c'est
bizarre regardez la partie avec Fab on
se disait que c'était mal joué la part
de Ding me regarde sans ordi avec femme
au début
français
on a vu ça
on a vu C5 et on a dit ok c'est Kappa
enfin
dès qu'on a vu F4 non mais nous on était
sur le coup
on est biaisé parce qu'on regarde avec
ordi et en fait sans ordi on a g-système
pot et cavaliers
5 d'abord même après tu quand tu
regardes un peu tu as fait
ah mais est-ce que non non faut F4 on
avait pas de suite mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que cavalier F6 faute à cause
de Damas 4 avec l'idée de ramener le fou
ça on l'avait instant oui mais là c'est
pour ça il avait nul en fait
de penser qu'elle allait faire nul et là
là il est pas bien là
mais si pense qu'il fait nul dans
l'autre
il fait nul et puis revient avec les
Blanco demain avec une petite ville de
Richard il met un petit pion
parce que peut-être que l'ordi va pas
dire que c'est une grosse faute dans les
mais en pratique en pratique c'est une
énorme erreur
un petit peu mais quand on voit les
erreurs sont l'ordi c'est que c'est
vraiment des fautes
on fait beaucoup de fautes
et ils sont
une petite pause allez on envoie la
petite pause
à tout de suite les amis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Vlad on est de on est de retour bah qui
va bientôt nous rejoindre il est aux
prises avec des échiquiers actuellement
il faut dire que il est bien prévu très
correctement la suite des événements
donc après avoir réfléchi dingue à
choisir d'imber 6 au lieu de dame de 8
dieu seul sait si dans plus fort que
dans toute manière d'embêter ça a une
gueule plus active donc il a choisi
par contre maintenant il faut trouver un
coup de rythme
pour cette je suppose bien probable que
c'est déjà une menace
surtout après de ta retourne vite parce
que ça a faiblir cette bien sûr donc
maintenant
le moment est très très important il
faut trouver le coup mais ça va pas être
facile Vlad pour
ok quand tu vois que tout F2 est mauvais
la première réactions c'est bien sûr de
jouer tout à 8 parce que comme ça au
moins tu oublies pas FC
cas là ça va être plus ou pareil parce
que
donc le pion 9 7 défendu j'ai un tempo
pour faire quelque chose j'ai que vos
livres 6
en 19 de gagner la dame tour de
de 8 puis je menace que vous voulez
descendre je suppose
donc c'est un peu
avant mais si je fais juste tourner un
pour tout empêcher ah il y a B2 en l'air
aussi
ok collectif d'ailleurs c'était pas le
seul coup d'ailleurs parce qu'il y avait
je viens de
voiristes recette
donc je peux rattraper la dame de
l'autre côté aussi donc pour cette non
[Musique]
tourader
bouge quelque part ça c'est le truc le
plus logique peut-être juste avant de
select qui viennent peut-être juste
considérant quel est les réactions de
noir après tu auras 28 faut que je sens
parce que c'est là où tout commence il
faut bien comprendre comment es-tu
réagis sur ça déjà on a un coup de tempo
autour de 4
et peut-être maintenant H6 avec la tour
sur des 4 années
un peu moins sensible
beaucoup plus sûr que il y aura quelque
chose
ok certes faut trois gagnants tempo
aussi mais il y a tour de 5 il y a
autour de 5 ici F4 on est content en
affirmer le type
on est content déjà en affirmer le type
donc ok tu auras de 8 dans ce cas là un
coup pratique avec la tour
FEA ou peut te
beaucoup d'options je vais pas faire
tourner 4 quand même
d'accord dans ce cas là il faut que tu
vois bien en avance que tu fais après
toi
j'ai pas
que je regarde la turbine
trop dur par contre sur ce quatrième
fois aussi
quatre fois
tu le trouves pas parce que tu vois tout
tu trouves parce que tu as pas trop de
choix ce que peut aider au noir pour
aider de tel trucs c'est que tu as pas
trop de choix juste
ouais ça c'est fort quand même comme
défense ouais mais bon dans ce match ils
ont jamais trouvé aucune défense
pourquoi il commencerait là bien
défendre
plutôt pacifique maintenant on voit que
base encore une fois pas vraiment en
fait
bon on va voir si la Torah D8 mais moi
je prédis que il va mal défendre et
perdre en moins de 20 coups à partir
d'ici peut-être même moins de 15 enfin
être perdant après moins de 15 coups je
repère dans où tu pourras abandonner
après il peut continuer comme un fou
furieux mais pour moi il va il va perdre
la digne je veux pas faire encore moins
pronostic non mais fais de pronostic
aussi je pense que il va faire tour à de
8 puis après le coup de Yann je vais
donner mes pronostic après ça dépend
quel coup il va choisir les gens disent
pourquoi c'est négatif bah dans ce
championnat du monde les défenses sont
assez médiocres jusqu'à maintenant et
les joueurs attaquent très bien ouais
c'est pour ce niveau c'est vraiment ça
défend mal et ça attaque très bien en
revanche et là on a de nouveau une
position avec un joueur un époque qui a
très bien attaqué depuis le début du
championnat du monde face à Ding qui a
pas réussi à opposer quelconque
résistance dans les positions ils
devaient défendre
mais je vois pas pourquoi aujourd'hui ça
serait différent
voilà ma théorie tiens je vais une
petite ligne que je voudrais bien me
montrer au spectateur tout rêve de 8
tours
E4 dans E7 dame
ranger deux maintenant mais il va jamais
avoir ça
encore plus beau
donc
ce qui compte maintenant
c'est en cas qui arrive parfois quand
vous
vous êtes en train d'apprendre une
nouvelle ouverture pour vous vous êtes
très bien théoriquement mais sur
l'échiquier vous êtes pas tout à fait à
l'aise parce que
ce qui est quand même pas dans un stand
qui est assez étonnant c'est que j'en
parlais avant à
discute un peu de la partie avec Fab
pour une fois sans ordi pour comparer et
genre nous avec Fab on n'est pas on est
on est nul on est d'accord
bah nous cavaliers ça nous a choqué sans
ordi c'est genre de cavaliers mais c'est
catastrophique de jouer comme ça et on
est pas si fort que ça enfin gérant
qu'on est quand même assez faible mais
tous les deux on aurait joué G6 bah
notre version ça a été que après tu as
du F5 tu as dû à ça enfin notre version
ça a été ko il était DAC pour new après
et il
est d'accord
mais après J6 c'est même les noirs qui
peuvent prétendre
bac tu es sûr que les Noirs comme quoi
c'est plus agréable de jouer
cette résumé
mais il est vrai que au moins
les problèmes du roi sont très
lointaines
ça donne la case H6 certes mais il y a
aucune attaque
tu vois après tu peux dire que des trucs
comme ça ça peut
ouais mais bon c'est hyper longtemps
hyper longtemps et par contre ça c'est
pas si lointain cavalier F4 est fou
projet de
non juste l'histoire comme tu viens de
dire d'ailleurs tu as bien noté ici dans
ce match
chaque fois ceux qui sont sont en
défense oublient des trucs en gros des
fois mal et ceux qui sont en attaque
sont hyper précis pour ça
jusqu'à présent tel square énorme le
pourcentage énorme juste après il y a
une victoire noir quand même il y a une
victoire avec les Noirs tout de même
j'oublie même et le fou fou tu te
rappelles pas le cavalier prend F6
ah oui oui oui oui
bah par contre
catastrophique faute
C2 il a fait pousser de Détroit fou d3c2
et puis de le conférence de presse il a
dit après il faut deux trois jours pour
F5 moi c'est le premier président
[Rires]
ouais donc c'est
ouais c'est compliqué pour pour les
défenseurs c'est pour ça que cette
position là dans ce match précisément je
vois pas comment il a défendre
parce qu'elle paraît vraiment dur avec
les noirs
mais si il perd comme ça c'est vraiment
en Fantin quoi
d'autre comment dire de se faire gourer
par un seul coup quoi c'est pas les
premières fois en fait
c'est devient plus ou moins une mauvaise
habitude dans ce machin
ok oui
là il réfléchit en tout cas il a il
plombe
qu'est-ce que je peux dire trop de trop
de ferry après le virtuel qui a marché
un peu trop bien mais là il peut
vraiment perdre en deux coups
mais peuvent
donc le nombre de pièces qui sont à
l'attaque de jeu attends est-ce qu'il
peut faire un tel coup que tout refait
il peut faire
non
si
peut-être il peut faire toi
et damage cette mate
mais si il peut
[Rires]
[Musique]
il sait qu'il va perdre non
je crois que tout le monde sait qu'il va
perdre ici toi moi tous les gens sur
twitch
comme tu dis que pourquoi est-ce que
j'ai
joué
maintenant il va jouer là il va jouer
pourquoi est-ce que je me suis dépêché
en cours une fois au pire moment
il va jouer il va jouer il va jouer
il a trouvé le coup good
par contre
comment dire les dernières alors
complications
pas mal de temps parce que il était bien
notable il était bien autant pour une
fois dans ce match et là d'un coup là
maintenant il est j'ai pas loin d'une
demi-heure de moins que son adversaire
et que c'est ce qu'on jouait et le papy
est toujours en danger donc
le scénario pas parmi les tops
maintenant
intéressante pour moi
est-ce que son adversaire qui a bien sûr
vu autour de 8
va vite fait jouer son cours je pense
que la vie de jouer tout radin parce que
en fait il y a des bonnes raisons de ne
pas jouer toi il y a des bonnes raisons
de jouer c'est pas toi mais tu auras
bien
tu menaces la directement faut prendre
ça de nouveau
je comprends moi quand tu joues tours
par exemple tu menaces
donc ramenez la 5e pièce à l'attaque
et c'est quand même
[Musique]
intéressant ça a l'air assez perspective
pour pouvoir tenir
vous voyez donc le problème de noir
c'est que le four sur E7 n'est pas de
fendiou par contre quand vous le
défendez par exemple avec tout fe8 plus
tard
peut-être F7 va devenir faible vous
voyez donc
en fait tu aurais fait 8 disons
pour 3
sale tu peux tu peux déjà être matte
dans deux coups
ça peut aller très très très très vite
plus la peine de déjà
en a parlé on a trouvé cette super idée
avec tour de 4 ouais et à la fin du
compte tour Eiffel comme quoi affaiblit
F2 dans les variantes donc c'est pour ça
que tu as
d'ailleurs dans vos deux il y a cette
fois assise le coup de l'ordi du coup
logique C4 ça c'est normal
regarde comment il défend l'ordi
oula et pourquoi pas pour ce cadre au
lieu de cavalier
ok mais trouvable ça en partie trouvable
donc voilà
et puis alors pour ce cadre et de
nouveau le noir auront en super cavaler
sur 200 je crois que c'est même pas ça
je crois juste que tu récupères la
qualité en force en fait
change juste que tu peux pas
tu peux vraiment pas empêcher kb4 là
moi peut-être et au lieu de cavalier
à gagner de toi
sans que ça ne risque OK
donc
comment est-ce que ça va tourner
ça ça sauve alors dans ce cas-là
parce que je suppose ce que tu viens de
montrer ça va plus marcher
ah oui un peu la même opération et
peut-être voici ce cadre est peut-être
pas envoyé tout doux à ne pas envoyer
H5 important en partant mais attention
parce que après
cavalier je suis ici ce machin agir
tour de garde voilà
et maintenant bah toi aussi tu es un peu
fou ces deux disons si je veux pas
réfléchir
assure-toi toujours ce connard de fois
ça revient ce connard de fois et là je
l'avais pas
ce qui est important aussi
important
alors ça veut dire que après faut se
dôme en auto
mais peut-être un football d'ailleurs
dans je veux dire d'ailleurs très
important les amis attends ici je fais
pourquoi je ferais pas tout reprendre
les amis une fois les Noirs ont rajouté
les coups froid les Noirs pourront en
prendre sur bedo parce qu'après tourbone
le four n'est pas ne plus avoir sur
Bruxelles c'est ça ce que très important
et ça ça donne quoi genre prise ou des
trois
bah
ça donne l'initiative pour les bois et
puis pour le noir
sinon bien sûr
reste compliqué les bons vieux soit fou
je sens soit je Cather soit cavalier de
7 les bons ont un tas de dés pour
essayer de frapper quand même sur
complexe
mais j'ai la façon éternelle de jouer
dans ces situations là j'ai attaqué le
fou tu l'as bougé je lui rends attaque
je le attaque par dams
éventuellement
mais mais tu le touches quand même moi
je le touche quand même je devant le je
défends mon fou sur cette aussi
au final est super intéressant de cette
partie bah en fait pour avoir des
parties intéressantes faut des fautes
quand il y a des erreurs les parties
sont nettement vive les fautes faut des
fautes dès qu'il y a une faute c'est la
partie devient beaucoup plus
intéressante mais il faut pas que la
faute soit trop grave
comme là en fait Cavaliere
c'est à la limite quoi et ça devient
serré
je joue beaucoup
c'est plus vivant
c'est quoi la faute la faute a été
collée
au 12e coup non au 13e
c'est vrai que ça donne envie donc Tour
Eiffel c'était peut-être le plus
intéressant au final parce que le truc a
trouvé très dur parce que s'il faut
trouver dan tour des 4
C3 c'est ce qu'on avait tout reprend des
trois prise D3 et C4 c'est vraiment dur
dur mais comme je dis quand tu as pas de
choix tu peux
mais je veux dire que pour le coup après
tout ce qu'on a dit pour moi c'est tout
référent le coup le plus intéressant
parce que ça demande au noir de trouver
quelque chose de très difficile
OK et si les Noirs trouvent pas et joue
comme dans l'autre variante alors faut
assise ces quatre tours de 4 mais là il
y a ça
j'oublie à chaque fois des trucs
ce que veut dire que peut-être
parce que quand tu fais
quand tu fais ça ça et ça
cavalier prend dame prend ça marche pas
parce qu'il y a la Tour Eiffel en l'air
ce qui est logique et pourtant qui après
fou et fond tour de Wood pas tour de 8
mais facile
donc tout F1 en fait c'est vraiment un
antidote contre X 6
tout en fait ça permet d'avoir
donc là dessus moi je dirais
5 ça donne quoi ah peut-être ça alors
pour les Noirs j'ai 6 fougères 5 tours
des 4 ou puissant
et sur dame mange 3 alors
certes ok tu peux maintenant
tu peux te réorganiser la dame cessen
la ligne Tour Eiffel 1 donc G6
mais G6
ça si tu veux perdre
en général juridique
en ouverte et peut-être même ouverte le
plus souvent F2
là les Siciliens par exemple
ok mais je vais faire c'est enfin j'ai
tout le temps faire C4 en fait
même dans les sicilium ouvert ce dernier
tome là les bons préfèrent de jouer de
mettre le pion sur F3 et pas sur F4
c'est dangereux non mais en plus là tu
as tu as un vis-à-vis direct
F4 affaiblit les diagra la grande
diagonales
[Musique]
donc
si vous travaillez pas dans un
club de strip-tease
ne faites pas F4
c'est un coup ou pas
[Musique]
si je veux pas réfléchir et si je veux
pas réfléchir
il faut à 8
ok mais disons que je me replace quoi
ah tu mets un tour ici donc peut-être B3
en fait je veux stabiliser mon cavalier
ici mon fou en E5 et venir
attaquer dans un deuxième temps
du moment
c'est petit pour des milliers de raisons
déjà je peux commencer par vous ce 4
précis c'est une construction s'il faut
se cadre de 5 fou et 6 c'est ok je
serais pas Madame cet article
tu te rappelles j'ai dit que je pense
des trois aussi il trouve ça il fait nul
oh dingue
le cou est pas top parce que l'ordi
propose G6 aussi pour tenir
sur X6 tours 94
toujours le même sur fou je sens comme
on a dit avant il y a toujours
c'est toujours pour des quatre en fait
écoutez j'ai une grosse sympathie pour
Ding mais surtout ce que j'aime c'est ça
tout sur dewitch Je l'aime à chaque fois
elle vient aussi court elle se déplace
sur des quatre et limite la dame dans
les lignes après force colère cette dame
7 elle se sacrifie sur deux trois en
fait
il a bien il a bien il a bien défendu
hein parce que c'était vraiment
difficile
donc
c'est soit X6 soit G6 mais je pense ça
va être G6 parce quoique tu sais quoi en
fait fois 6 C4 reprend des trois c'est
quand même pas si dur
ok
c'est pas si dur en fait tu gagnes un
tempo là tu veux bouffer C4 n'oublie pas
quand il faut pas se défendre mais il
faut jouer actif il peut trouver
tu te rappelles de la partie précédente
plus ou moins tout le monde de partager
en deux parties ceux qui voient bien la
tactique pour l'adversaire ce que voit
bien les tactiques pour eux-mêmes bien
sûr c'est le deuxième catégorie et ceux
qui voit rien
la troisième catégorie
pas le plus petit
mais il me fait flipper là quand même
pas comme ça mais quand on met les
doigts comme ça ce qui est un peu joyeux
un un peu joyeuse c'est que en ce sens
respirer assassin respirer ressent en
vie c'est un peu joyeux en fait c'est un
peu coquin je vais dire
oh vas-y mon petit coquin voici ce tour
de toi
il peut trouver
on le sent
quand même un peu stressé je vais un peu
joyeux mais un peu stressé quand il lui
reste plus qu'à 40 minutes faudrait pas
qu'il prenne trop de temps non plus là
parce qu'il y a pas les 30 secondes par
coup jusqu'au 40e
même jusqu'au 60e d'ailleurs
une chose c'est de calculer les
variantes défensives une chose de
calculer les variantes tu attaques
X4 c'est tout à fait un autre état
d'esprit
je me rappelle c'était d'ailleurs le
slogan de ta chaîne oui stream c'est un
état d'esprit c'est ça
en tout cas pour cette ligne à plan de
la agressif je donne 60 % pour J6
après 40 % pourquoi c'est je donne même
pas 40% pour Jessie je donne de 10 à 15%
. voilà et le reste c'est pour un autre
cours en 3e
tour Eiffel 8
ok Tour Eiffel 8 ça peut
n'empêche tu peux commencer parfois si
après c'est 4 faire un autre coup
voici ce C4 et maintenant peut-être un
petit peu faire
tourner 4 maintenant
et moi je monte tu bouges parce que
c'est logique et tour là quelque part
et j'ai ici finalement
au pire
tu peux toujours avoir des trucs comme
ça
je sais pas si là ça marche mais je veux
dire tu peux toujours avoir des trucs
comme ça
en fait le sonnerie est typique pour les
parties quand mes pages joue que au lieu
de dos à la française toujours rien à la
sortie d'ouverture
il continue à faire le coup pratique
comme dans cette partie et puis à un
moment donné il invite-moi ça arrive sur
les petites tactiques à l'île du roi
c'était bien le scénario de toutes ces
parties compteur Sacha dans cette
ouverture qu'est-ce que je dois voir G6
il a joué aussi
bon tu es étonné très étonné par contre
je suis content quand même parce que
paraît-il qu'il y aura pas de mode
c'est pas mal quand même
c'est quand même blindé d'ailleurs
fois 6 tours
c'est important quand même que
la dame sur B6 se contrôle le 6 tout à
l'heure la dame a été très mauvaise
parce que n'a jamais défendu au 7 et
dans ce cas là après faut acheter
[Musique]
un pion peut-être
un jour quand le fou n'est pas sur bossé
donc après les fouilles
elle peut bouffer à tout moment
alors presque deux fois plus du temps
pour
Yann
les positions quand vient
par contre faut prendre maintenant les
décisions parce que les perspectives de
l'attaque peuvent s'évaporer dans quoi à
l'autre il faut donc trouver les moyens
d'opposer des problèmes tendre des
pièges etc
il va trouver les pièges oui oui
après l'ouverture il pouvait pas espérer
un aussi bon scénario Yann
c'est un fiasco c'est un grain optimiste
c'est un grand optimiste d'ailleurs
plutôt faire ça plus grand force aux
échecs en fait il croit toujours à son
étoile
comment dire bienveillance
et donc sur X6 tours 8 d'un F4 c'est
tour des 4 c'est ça ouais
important quand même le tour des quatre
là pour chasser la dame
très important comment touch
c'est un coup qui fait une grande
différence
et si je change mon foot diagonale
base je suppose celui du sens parce que
j'ai toujours des coups confit de ça
que tu touches tu touches tout de suite
non non non non non
attends il a joué mais il y avait
cavalier des 5 je crois juste en fait
facile pourtant
ah oui en fait il joue peut-être pour
gagner avec les noirs
8 pour décaler la tour et fouger 5
peut-être ah non peut-être
non quelque chose hein
je pense que non on en a parlé déjà je
pense peut-être qu'on l'a eu pour ça oui
oui
pour protéger le fou exactement mais ça
on était content avec les Noirs bah oui
parce que
figurons-nous monsieur spectateurs mais
après cavalière 5 c'est pas les bras qui
vont m'attaquer non c'est les Noirs
parce que
tempo mais il serait pas en train de
complètement déconner Yann
bah il est né pour
il va se barrer encore mais tu sais
qu'il est je pense qu'il est beaucoup
plus nerveux Yann que Ding pour la
raison suivante on a remarqué pendant
les matchs de championnats du monde déjà
que le joueur qui se lève sans arrêt
c'est un signe de nervosité
on a déjà remarqué ça
parce que
j'ai pas tu as envie de contempler la
belle scène où je parle les belles
spectatrices tu te tu te lèves tout
simplement parce que tu peux plus rester
assis parce que trop de stress parce que
comme quoi c'est un flamant et de
l'intention
ton arrière il a juste une crise
d'hémorroïdes
peut-être on sait pas en fait trop de
grenades bouffées
pas que des grenades à mon avis
non mais genre c'est possible en fait
mais les gens vont penser que c'est une
blague ou quoi mais ça peut être une
raison en fait non mais réellement
ça t'amuse ça vous amuse tous mais vous
êtes toujours sur des théories bizarres
ça vous amuse c'est pas drôle
c'est pas fun oh que non
à force de mettre des blocs tu as mal au
cul quoi
[Rires]
mais c'est vrai que ça joue moins bien
depuis les délais les machins des trucs
pas compris je dis c'est vrai que
globalement dans les échecs ça joue un
peu moins bien depuis l'arrivée du délai
des contrôles
ah donc pas étonnant que certains est
mal aux fesses quoi
en Ding qui réfléchit en tout cas
il faut se dépêcher quand même
c'est la seule chose qui montre qui est
en fait
parce qu'il en reste à faire encore
pratique comme coup mais bon tu perds un
peu de pression là peut-être il va faire
cavalier de 5
vous prend le 7 cavalier prend le 7 mais
t'as pas peur d'un cavalier G4 là
est-ce que tu peux pas défendre comme ça
genre
ok bien sûr tu veux que le R5 etc mais
bien sûr le premier coup de banque
n'est-ce pas
donc
le cavalier et peut-être F4 maintenant
pour pouvoir jouer secrète déjà il faut
comprendre l'idée je les comprends pas
encore disons
c'est
bien ça
tours E2 peut-être tu vas envoyer
non en fait je peux pas jouer ça ah non
ok tu bouffes si tu veux rien calculer
ce 4
qui est-ce qui va pas ok tu rajoutes oui
tu rêves de 8 oui par exemple il
retourne
là maintenant toujours
parce que tu menaces maintenant dans ce
5 ou à chanter
non
ça fait pas trop peur quand même et
c'est toi d'abord
je joue sur le même principe
c'est vraiment chiant maintenant moi
par contre pas si simple il est plus
facile de jouer danse 7 qui au dame de 8
parce que tu veux toujours garder l'oeil
sur le cavalier
C3 c'était le problème et si je reviens
juste là
ah non non personne revient là tout le
monde
le rêve d'offensif 4 est tel que tu sais
ça avec toutes les forces
en fait ici
non mais ça va en fait qu'est-ce qu'on
s'est emmerdé tout à l'heure avec ces
quatre tu peux tu peux en fait on
s'emmerde pas en fait jusqu'à vallée H5
le foufou soit il échange
6 pour bouge et il faut calculer que les
FC
tour de toi
non ça c'est trouvable
même les aveugles
[Musique]
ça me fait pas peur et toujours encore
et encore l'ordi fait G4 et tout mais ça
me fait pas peur du tout en fait
et c'est hyper dangereux pour les deux
parlons de ces quatre est-ce que tu
penses que Ding connais cette chanson
d'Amélie Bent
le point levé non
justement ça le problème
non ça va aller ça va aller ça va aller
Vlad
yes j'avais
[Applaudissements]
après quoi sur le point le vin non non
un truc et puis bah toujours le poil le
vin
bon elle alors est-ce que tu penses
qu'il y a un autre coup encore pour Ding
euh
un a dit que voler de 5 on a dit
le coup le plus tranquille
mais après dans ce 7 excuse-moi
mais il faut acheter
je veux pas faire semblant que je peux
regarder maintenant c'est que
l'ordinateur donne parce que ici
l'ordinateur dans C4 j'aurais pas trouvé
et ça c'est vraiment dur mais cavaliers
H5 l'autre coup de l'ordi aussi
c'est un coup tu enlèves
tu enlèves la protection de 6 way
donc damage 3 bien joué
parce que ça souligne les problèmes
possibles sur casse blanche
[Musique]
très bon coup
ok donc à valider 5 on repart par là
tour de weed moins de dégâts
[Musique]
donc ok si jamais
une question
dans ce cas-là
le sacrifice d'Orient
il peut utiliser les cases noires
autrement
il peut essayer de jouer damarchie avec
les dettes
je m'en fous Royal moi je joue collecson
je serai jamais mandats
tu veux me proposer une je sais pas
d'accord
non non avec un téléphone
pire contre personne
et je serai content quand même
tu mets ton Cavaillon F5 ouais
je veux me faire réfléchir de toute
façon je suis pas capable donc sur quoi
que ce soit je peux coller
au secours au secours ouais ça c'est une
bonne ça c'est une bonne option donc
cavalier dessin plutôt oui
mais il faut qu'il joue à quand même
parce que 25 minutes ça commence à oui
il a plus qu'une minute parcours
derrière
sans le rajoute c'est pas beaucoup hein
bah oui
de 5 là c'est sûr
on n'a pas regardé dans D8 du tout
première réaction X il faut donner le
tour
c'est le premier réaction donc ça marche
pas non c'est cavaliers des 500% en fait
c'est que cavalier dessin qui s'y dams
c'est trop dur trop de problèmes
oui il faut voir après que
[Musique]
il y a que olive
oui mais c'est bien joué s'il a vu X6 et
ouais c'est encore mieux en fait
si on s'attendait pas dame c'est 7 c'est
parce que c'est hyper bien joué
il veut cavaler H5 ou C4 ok c'est 4
c'est pour les heures
et soir que voilà
il faut fuite admettons
s'active et d'ailleurs tu es devenu
actif depuis pas trop longtemps
[Musique]
n'empêche peut-être tu as raison enfin
je veux pas jouer depuis 6 ans je sais
plus où qu'est-ce que est dur qu'est-ce
que n'est pas dur ça me paraît dur
mais après tu es pas obligé tu peux
faire fois 6 cavalier H5 faut prendre et
prendre direct
la menace est plus forte que l'exécution
est sur je crois tu fais ce cadre ouais
ça c'est facile ça c'est facile ça c'est
facile
OK
les
choses se chauffent
ouais ça peut ça peut tourner dans un
sens ou dans l'autre
dans le meilleur coup c'est qu'il a tout
calculé après peut-être pas tout mais il
a aussi le feeling qui est bien passé ce
qui a beaucoup de beaucoup de choses
mais bon
mais sur ces trois c'est ouais ouais sur
sur H5 et sur C3 on a dit c'est hors des
tu touches là et sur F4 c'est C4
oui bah parce que
c'est 4 même non on avait cavalier H5
nous mais une fois le pion F bouge et
affaibli le deuxième ça donne du
contre-jour pour l'éternité vous
cherchez tout de suite comment se
retrouver sur la deuxième tout de suite
sur les rageux de la bouffe donc dans
ces cas-là c'est 4 devient tout à fait
logique parce que une fois aller à tour
arrive sur des deux bah ça y est elle
est capable de bouffer
c'est que les meilleurs coups
depuis
pour les Noirs depuis cavalier F6
c'est marrant
il voit après
et en fait là on voit de nouveau
comprendre une
Anne-Sophie on fait le Sophie ce qui est
pour pouvoir gagner il faut d'abord
perdre nos une faute pour
déstabiliser la position
et puis au foot les meilleurs coups en
gros les carrières d'un très grand
joueur Alexandre Hermès
et on se demandait moi je me suis
demandé à chaque fois mais avant
commencer de jouer comme un génie est-ce
que il est foutu une faute exprès ou pas
et tu as déjà répondu
parce que j'ai jamais
toi tu avais un très bon score contre
il a toujours cherché à
échauffé le truc et moi à chaque fois
c'est un bon score contre lui
je pense que j'ai plus d'eux
et en classique zéro ça veut dire gagner
une perdue celle que tu as gagné était
plus importante
beaucoup beaucoup
Yann qui revient là il peut déconner
Yann
parce que X ça peut mal tourner et ces
trois F4 aussi
en fait
c'est quoi le conflit de bon en fait
essayons de
construire
le cavalier on sent que quoi en mer la
tour des quatre reconquois très actif et
chiante maintenant alors en plus jouer
ces trois mais ça se déstabilise les
positions du haut blanc sur du toit on
peut jouer F4 pour défendre le cavalier
5 etc mais ça affaiblit gravement le roi
blanc donc c'est ça le conflit en fait
c'est que pour pouvoir attaquer il faut
affaiblir quelque chose il est noir
revient et frappe tout de suite sur le
point où tu t'es affaibli en fait et ça
c'est le premier problème de bon et le
deuxième c'est psychologique depuis
plusieurs cours c'est les bras qui
attaquent avec chaque coup donc en plus
haut donc prendre les tendances de
continuer mais ça peut être fautive en
fait tu peux avoir l'impression que tu
vas que tu dois jouer un coup comme tout
droit ou fois 6 ou quoi parce que tu
drive quoi
et peut-être tu rêves d'ailleurs
exactement
dans les vraie vie qu'est-ce que c'est
vrai
c'est des petites des petites pierres
ça peut faire très mal tu tombes dans du
gravier c'est déjà tombé dans du gravier
non ça fait mal
tu glisses quoi
le mot est assez bizarre d'ailleurs
je peux me donner que c'est pas un mot
russe
ça fait mal au genou et au coude ouais
[Musique]
parce que
je le dis avec un très fort accent
c'est déjà arrivé d'avoir des graviers
dans ta chaussure ah oui c'est vrai ça
mille fois oui bien sûr
ils disent que ça vient du latin
presque tout en français
alors sinon
25 minutes presque pile pour Ding
54 pour Yann et demi même donc en gros
avantage au temple une demi-heure
par contre
mon expérience tu sais
quand tu vois pas quoi faire exactement
une demi-heure de plus mais ça passe
vite quand tu sais pas quoi faire bien
sûr maintenant il faut il faut vraiment
prendre une décision quand tu continues
d'offrir le Bourron
c'est très facile mais peut-être faut-il
et donc
devenir sage c'est hyper dur dans cette
situation
en fait moi je pense que moi j'aurais
pensé avec les Blancs que je suis proche
de gagner quand même
normal normal
parce que complètement évident pour toi
pour l'adversaire que et les camions
faute oui c'est clair pour vous vous
deux en fait le problème c'est que c'est
ce n'est pas si moi la fête parce que
depuis il est toujours bien joué et
c'était pas si moi est-ce que view comme
à quel point il est bien joué plus tard
après il faut faire attention comme je
le répète mais il y a pas les 30
secondes par coup donc ça peut passer
très très vite pour les deux maintenant
il y a pas 30 secondes par contre c'est
pour ça
que tu dis 25 minutes pour 20 coups
c'est quand même pas beaucoup hein
violence surprend les droits non c'est
pas ça fait vraiment longtemps que j'ai
pas joué avec quelqu'un danse
parce que je suis pas jouer les matchs
même à l'époque
donc pas de rajout ça peut digne il faut
quand même qu'il fasse attention
il faut attendre
et il adresse à faire vente en cours
25 minutes pour une minute par coup
c'est pas énorme dans une position
complexe comme ça mais après il a dû
beaucoup calculer déjà en amont donc il
a peut-être 4-5 coups qui vont être
faciles après ça peut simplifier
bah ça va s'amplifier simplifier surtout
si après que les R5 ne change les les
fous plus d'attaque ok là après vous
pouvez faire le truc c'est que s'il
trouve ces quatre ça peut encore se
complexifier
tu sais quoi
je pense Yann n'a pas choisi le bouton
est-ce que c'est si ordinateur comment
tu sauves ton truc on est complètement
tarés avec toi pourquoi bah tu joues
quoi avec les Blancs
c'est hyper facile pourquoi on a parlé
de cavalier H5 bah parce que peut-être
elle va pas trouver ces quatre
différentes
ici j'ai pas peur mais du coup qu'est-ce
qui peut avoir en fait parce que faut
agissez 4 en réalité on n'a pas on a
pensé que c'était dur mais en fait juste
attaque le fou il y a pas faut deux il y
a dame prend le 5 et dis-moi tu dois
reprendre que avec le roi ou tu peux
reprendre avec le frein je pense non tu
peux reprendre avec le fou aussi bah
dans ce cas là reprendre avec le fou
pour moi simplement oui non mais je
m'étais juste le truc main de l'ordi
mais même faut pas en fait c'est hyper
facile en fait on est juste con avec toi
patata que le fou il a pas de cases il
va en eux il y a dame prend E5 et ici il
prend ses quatre tu reprends bon c'est
pas non plus enfin c'est pas la banque
la plus compliquée qu'ils aient eu à
calculer donc en fait il y a pas fou H6
du tout donc ça veut dire que c'est
vraiment ces trois tours des cinq
est-ce que tu serais pas dans la merde
en fait
non moi je me demande juste que il est
possible aussi que mes pots n'a pas
choisi le bon moment de réfléchir non il
aurait peut-être dû réfléchir un coup
avant oui parce que
pendant que le réfléchir
Ding cherche et sur ma trouve tous ces
quatre tout se finissent là il va être
bien armé une fois dit Yann va
finalement faire un truc intéressant du
coup pourquoi pas B3 B3 bah parce que
c'est dégueulasse
je peux pas parce que vous êtes sûr que
à partir de maintenant c'est vous qui
euh
en force en fait vous voyez donc c'est
juste comment je sais c'est peut-être
objectivement ça va mais c'est
dégueulasse du point de vue que
pendant 1h30 vous vous aviez attaqué oui
et maintenant d'un coup
je dois me défendre c'était très très
dur cette chose cet échange de de la
mise en scène
c'est parmi les choses les plus
violentes
a été bon mais l'équipe russe a un
affaire en génie purudio tant qu'il
s'agit de blanc donc rapporte et on peut
rien faire avec insigne a été
fantastique quand il s'agissait de moi
je pense qu'il faisait
donc parce qu'avec les blancs
rapportent seul devienne facilement
l'équipe de Rosco
soit de cinq gens soit de 10 ans soit
deux je passe 50 jambes mais rapporte
seule
leur donner complètement
bravo
un rapport c'est vrai qu'il a il a
apporté déjà trois idées intéressantes
avec les Blancs pour Ding et c'est pas
la fin c'est pas la fin et à chaque fois
c'était des coups c'est comme la
guérilla quoi c'est des petites
escargots à gauche à droite
d'ailleurs peut-être il doit écrire
moment de livre à la fin du match
rapporte comment j'ai trouvé des petits
mais en tout cas ça joue bien côté Ding
aujourd'hui c'est la première belle
défense du championnat du monde parce
que cette position là elle était pas
facile et c'est la première fois dans ce
match qu'on a un joueur qui trouve des
défenses très solides et qui trouve les
meilleurs coups quand il est en
dangereux
jusque maintenant le match était très
intéressant mais par contre il est vrai
parfois les qualités un peu souffert
c'est pas qui ont un puriste mais les
qualités se faire peut-être bien trop
parfois et bon on est quand même pour
que il y a des des parties
où les deux joueurs jouent bien en même
temps ouais c'était pas le cas c'était
pas le cas il jouait bien mais
vous vous souvenez comment s'écrouler
[Musique]
tout seul dans la partie précédente avec
le noir et puis
avant-hier
ce que faisait Yann avec le noir
ils ont tous les ils ont mal défendu
tout simplement mais tu vois
mais c'est bien joué
il empêche ses quatre en fait
en gros il se dit le solides
C4 moins
il veut dire que ok tu fais que
je veux faire très solide je veux jouer
très solide je veux bander
maintenant non non je cherche plus de
maths non attention quand même parce
qu'il y a qu'un coup pour égalité c'est
Dame 3 cavalier F4 et F3 mais bon après
c'est logique quand tu fous de dame
pourrait réveiller à 5h du matin
après ça compte pas quand c'est toi qui
le dis
pourquoi parce que tu es souvent bourré
ça peut pas compter réveiller à 5h du
mois dans un bar américain
ok là c'est plus rare oui dans un bar
américain
par terre et passionné avec une
bouteille ici
je joue quand même dans mes trois
d'ailleurs
[Rires]
[Musique]
il faut quand même vérifier
va pas être joué ou F4 mais F4 c'est
attends attends ça il peut faire
que lui peut faire bon
non non
normalement on tremble un peu hein
mais bon on essaye de mettre un peu de
suspense comme ça prend un peu de temps
et de voir toutes les options possibles
oui c'est vrai c'est beau mais c'est la
beauté elle a
elle est à Baudelaire quoi vous rappelez
de ce vers les comment s'appelle la
charogne
décomposé quoi
H6 mais faut H6 ouais cavalière 4 il
veut quoi il faut prendre F4
dame G3
ah parce que sur ton D4 la cavalier
plongée 6
ça il peut avoir un époque
[Musique]
6 cavalier F4 fou prend F4 tours F4 dam
G3
G5 seul coup
mais jouable mais jouable en fait bon ok
j'ai pas vu ok moi c'est moi réfléchir
alors ok peut-être pas comme je vais
encore comment j'ai encore 23 minutes 26
secondes je veux peut-être retrouver un
auteur cours
je peux peut-être un juste retourner
juste ici prendre maintenant je pense
et tu tapes
tu butes
les variantes qui a calculé
ok faut acheter alors Caval F4
mais je sens que ça me paraît pas
insurmontable
est-ce que ça peut très bien tourner ça
pour les Noirs
par contre Ding en général avec les
Noirs il joue assez souvent les jeux 5
d'ailleurs avec les branches je pense il
est pas que nous pour le G4
je pense que une de ces parties
fantastiques vous aviez analysé sur ta
chaîne
quand il y a écrasé
qu'est-ce que c'est dur comme partie
aujourd'hui
bon écoutez j'adore les parties du jour
il est beaucoup plus tranchée que
d'habitude d'habitude
les noirs des cons très vite après elle
est sortie de virtuours et ils sont par
terre
en fait les parties d'avant les symboles
beaucoup plus a commencé
[Musique]
avec les pieds plutôt se défendre ça se
termine toujours mal est-ce que l'autre
le but avec les pieds aussi oui oui oui
mais c'est pas évident
je pense que c'est aussi un art martial
non
il se foutent par terre
je crois qu'ils ont raison c'est plutôt
la capoeira ah c'est peut-être pourquoi
est-ce que je pensais que c'est
brésilienne parce que pendant longtemps
les plus fort ça a été les frères
brésiliens je me rappelle plus de leur
nom mais les plus grands champions on
était a été une famille des combattants
comment les appelait combattants ou j'ai
pas comment on va attendre les
combattants Brésiliens en fait
voilà
un frère Gracie oui oui je pense que ils
sont quatre ou cinq ils sont tous fous
et tout
écoute à tout à l'heure je voudrais pour
un petit instant
bah pour les premières fois depuis
longtemps
je vais ressembler
depuis une heure Vlad oui depuis 1h
ouais tu lui dis depuis longtemps
il en prend beaucoup
tu veux souffler
tes micros spécialement pour toi donc je
me mets là
un moment il pouvait mettre un peu de
pression avec les Blancs et sinon là ça
reste compliqué
deux trois coups avant j'ai regardé
alors nous on a pas un gros ordi non
bien sûr mais c'était juste pour dire
que son fou G5 il est un peu à ce moment
là peut-être damage 3 ça donne attends
est-ce que j'ai le contrôle de la souris
j'ai peur de faire une bêtise
ici alors attends j'ai fait des photos
Twitter mais j'ai pris ça paraissait
plus fort
on va aller un peu sur le direct
puisque regarde attendez juste je veux
quand même rappeler les bases j'ai dit
peut-être que Yann peut jouer F4 ici
Vlad m'a dit impossible
pour moi parce que faut ranger 5 et je
prends G5 il y a pas cavalier 4 quand
même juste
je sais pas on n'a pas pu analyser du
tout parce que là il m'a dit impossible
non c'est pas mais c'est un coup
ouais
c'est pour ça F4 alors que F4 là alors
soit on est très mal après fou ranger 5
et ranger 5 et 200
c'était prévu pour que ce soit toi qui
soit ici le chef cavalier F4
monte monte je vous laisse trouver avec
elle je vous laisse regarder un petit
peu cavalier prend G2 je pense qu'il
faut prendre aussi
et la tour elle est clouée il y a pas
d'échec
ouais ça fait très peur ça ok bon l'ordi
nous donne ces quatre ici
c'est dur à voir c'est dur alors ça fait
la casse C5 c'est ça pour la dame ouais
oui oui quand même c'est pas si dur en
fait parce que
on est on tape G2 roh H1 il faut ranger
de maths
par contre
et en maths
en G7
je dirais que ici tu vois même un coup
comme ça il faut le réfuter
mais c'est encore C4 pas facile comme ça
très très difficile donc F4 bien joué
après c'était pas si clair non la partie
pardon
ça change la couleur de l'écran on voit
que c'est pas
l'échiquier d'analyse
et sur ces trois
il tape F4
et prendre 5 et jouer la cale de moins
ouais mais laquelle de moi
ça peut gagner des deux côtés la partie
elle est folle là et en plus il y a peu
de temps 20 21 minutes sans rajoutant et
39 minutes sans rajouter en 21e c'est
non la partie elle est belle parce que
depuis une quinzaine de coup là il y a
vraiment que un moment je vais juste le
montrer vite fait quand même c'est
vraiment un moment comme il est en train
de réfléchir donc c'est vraiment le
moment charnière ici
ça a été très bien joué mais ici damage
3 c'est un peu comme Vlad disait
on a regardé tout à l'heure une variante
comme ça en fait ici on pouvait jouer
damage 3
parce qu'il y a plus les tours des 4 là
et la meilleure ligne c'était cavalier
H5 x 6 c'est un peu dans le même style
et B3
qui revenait ouais mais damash3 profil
active
là c'est plutôt les blancs qui
poussaient tu vois avec plutôt entre tu
peux avoir perdu
jusqu'à maintenant en termes de niveau
de jeu c'est la meilleure partie du
match
à part j'aime pas trop le cas enfin
j'aime pas trop la réflexion après le
cavalier F6 de Ding c'est vrai qu'il a
joué ces cinq dame B6 quand même
comparativement aux autres parties il y
a vraiment eu des glissades là il y en a
pas eu un bonjour
c'est la première fois que ça défend
vraiment aussi bien joué ces trois
G5 c'était introuvable donc on dit quoi
la C3 qui a validé attends c'est trois
c'est tourpro F4 plutôt que va les
prendre
ouais parce que si cavalier prend
F4
tout reprend E5 il y a tout reprend D3
oh là là je pense c'est plutôt te
reprendre non j'ai envie de mettre
l'ordi là parce que c'est dur
mais on va voir écoute on admire aussi
il reste de toute façon ça va jouer
relatif ça ne peut plus que jouer vite
je voudrais juste savoir comprendre en
fait ici
tout reprend
possible en fait c'est trop dur on peut
pas là on peut vraiment pas expliquer en
plus hein
il peut pas prendre ouais ça a l'air
juste gagnant pour les blancs en fait
il a pas peur de cette
reprend F4 je pense qu'il a loupé faut
prendre ici
en fait c'est ton profil
parce que ça ok ça ça a l'air très
facile quand même
pour les noirs
j'ai 6 loupéen dingeren qui est un peu
de chance là sur cette surprise
mais bon la position est tellement
compliquée que il en faut un petit peu
après c'est vrai que ouais sinon si
c'est pas fou des 6 c'est foutranger ça
sinon c'est juste moins bien en fait
pour plusieurs raisons
[Musique]
ouais parce que fou c'est 4
il va jouer quand même ce cavalier prend
j'imagine je pense que bizarre
je pense c'est plutôt mieux pour les
Noirs ici
mais après le matériel il est pas
ouais non c'est mieux pour les Noirs
c'est mieux c'est clairement plus simple
à jouer
faut pas prendre des ah bah voilà faut
pas prendre
ce que j'aime bien les fous sur les
diagonales mais après il peut tenir ici
ça doit pas non plus être ok voyons ce
qu'il fait
plus que 34 minutes pour Yann 21 pour
dingly Rennes 19 quoi à jouer
c'est pour ça que c'est aussi dur là qui
des deux côtés
parce que ça peut être le
l'équivalent de la sixième partie du
match
Carlson n'est pas la grosse partie
l'avait perdue n'est pas et il s'était
écroulé et là il est un peu dans un
scénario d'une partie qui peut
ressembler à mi-match c'est
là oh là là oh que non surtout il y a
déjà la journée de repos demain le
cogite
comme au tennis le septième jeu à trois
partout c'est pareil on dit toujours que
c'est le jeu charnière d'insectes
qui nous dit qu'il a commencé à calculer
tout seul aussi ouais c'est trop dur
c'est trop dur c'est trop dur prends
deux trois dolipranes quand même
attention ne le fait pas parce que ça
peut être dangereux aussi mais bon on
comprend que tu as mal à la tête
là faut pas ouais c'est dur
ok oui ces trois il y a jamais de F6 il
y a de me prendre aussi ses chèques
F6 ouais en général il y aura toujours
un sacrifice un truc d'ailleurs oui il
pouvait pas jouer F6 au coup d'avant à
cause de dame prend ici c'est chèque il
y avait beaucoup de variantes où il y
avait des menaces de prises c'est
infernal cette française parce que il y
a les fous des deux côtés qui tape des
deux côtés en fait c'est et puis c'est
pas des fous de cave quoi qui te protège
le roi c'est des fous qui font que
attaquer mais qui défendent pas
là je sais pas quoi je sais pas quoi
dire
est-ce que alors non mais il peut
trouver quand même alors C3
C3 et pourquoi pas sur ces trois tours
F4
si on n'a pas pu trouver
je voulais je voulais jeter un œil à ça
mais les coups
on essaie de trouver là
la tête là il faut que je m'entraîne
pour le title j'ai le title à 17h
normalement je veux bien que je
m'entraîne un peu
je veux bien mais bon tu es
là tout tout le monde il y a fab qui
twitte sur Saint-Étienne tu vois
la partie est trop compliquée
et ces trois tours
non parce que ce que on veut pas c'est
ces trois tours F4 full F4 qui va aller
prendre F4
c'est trop complexe là c'est trop
complexe
je voulais voir pourquoi mais en fait
oui parce qu'on garde les fous et 4
ouais bah on y était il faut prendre ces
trois et tours c'est un fou D4 offrant
des quatre et maintenant Thor c'est un
ordi donne et c'est foutran G6 là ah
c'est ah oui mais la fantastique faut
prendre un je crois qu'on va mater
6 quelque part et si AG et ben là hop on
décale d'un Français 3 c'est dur hein
ils sont peur pour moi pour ma capacité
en title
déjà j'espère qu'ils vont jouer cette
heure en fait
même si ce peut suffire puisqu'on aurait
on fait le on fait le résumé donc 6h30
ça te à 6h45 ça te faut qu'elle dure
longtemps cette partie Yann qui suit
trop dur très très dur là
ça fait combien attends ils ont combien
de temps de jeu là ils ont déjà
ils ont trois heures et c'est pas des
trois heures facile parce qu'ils sont
sortis de l'ouverture très vite après je
pense pas que la partie elle dure elle
dure très longtemps en terme de temps
parce qu'avec aussi peu de temps à la
pendule ça va s'arrêter quoi ça va
s'arrêter enfin c'est soit ça va faire
nul soit il va y avoir un chaos à mon
avis il va falloir la sieste avant le
title
cette partie peut finir sur chaos juste
mais ça peut être des deux côtés je
pense qu'il va trouver le fou prend G6
regarde là il a l'air ouais il l'a
trouvé là il a
ah oui ah oui là
il l'a mais bon ça veut pas dire ouais
mais bon ouais mais alors si là
est-ce qu'il est obligé de prendre F4
déjà il a l'air
on en connaît des comme ça c'est pas le
premier c'est pas le premier encore
si tu es un peu d'imagination tu vois
apparemment
tu es en parade ouais là il serait très
très bien parce que du coup ça nous
lance sur cette variante forcée
on va revenir sur les coups d'avant mais
là on sent qu'il l'a trouvé ça nous
arrive là-dessus mais là ça a l'air
vraiment très bien pour les blancs grâce
au casse blanc et au casse noir
mais l'ordi l'ordi ne donne pas de alors
le problème c'est qui attends ça donne
quoi ça il y a pas incroyable Damien
échec d'aborder
la tour elle peut pas venir sur la
colonne à chouette c'est même là ouais
mais là on s'en sort on s'en sort sur la
limite
il va pas être bien de pas la gagner
s'il trouve tout ça
ouais c'est beaucoup trop compliqué on
est désolé mais bon c'est championnats
du monde là on essaie de trouver un peu
un peu la vérité et si la
Ding a passé c'est pas possible
impossible
[Rires]
c'est terrible mais ils ont alors et
c'est là que que le coup de chance
arrive c'est que ça ça peut être juste
complètement perdant et en fait parce
qu'il est en train de le voir et ici
c'est prendre des quatre
ça a l'air mieux pour les blancs mais là
comme ça si on trouve pas tout de suite
alors tour H4 maths pas et toi F6 on a
regardé tout reprend le 5 matépin tout
rept6 menace pas grand chose tout de
suite menace de menaces fortement quoi
de menacer
noir clairement les pions les cases
blancs s'il y a un échange de dames ça
va être mieux pour les noirs
ça ça doit être normalement mieux pour
pour les blancs mais comment il tient la
l'ordi d'un roi G7
tout rêve 2 par exemple
maintenant il dit que ça va
G7 c'est un coup de chance d'avoir
croisé ça toi
en fait c'est juste là ah oui d'accord
ok
non il y a pas eu de
j'ai l'impression qu'il avait joué
désolé non non mais pas grave donc ouais
bon la position finale ça a l'air
gagnant pour les blancs
je pense pas qu'il a calcule je pense
qu'il vérifie que ça soit seul seul coup
parce que de toute façon on a envie de
jouer ces trois
il recolle autant mais là il réfléchit
au bon moment
il réfléchit au bon moment mais là ils
vont plus avoir de moments pour
réfléchir ça va être ça la difficulté
c'est que là gérer le temps ça va être
compliqué tu peux pas te permettre de
temps 15 minutes sur un coup là tu peux
plus
foot6 et non mais de toute façon il y a
pas d'autres coups en fait si la
foufrangé ici il a pas d'autre coup ici
non mais il va faire C3 à moins attends
à moins qu'ici parce que fou C4 ça peut
taper un petit peu quand même
ça en plus
alors là est-ce qu'il fait du cinéma
parce qu'il a vu ses prend des cartes et
qui trouve pas de gains
c'est trop dur c'est trop dur c'est trop
dur
mais faut prendre ça ressemble un peu
aux dames D8 qu'il a loupé hier mais il
va géométrie
il va trouver c'est du bol ouais il va
se ressaisir
ouais c'est chaud là c'est très très
chaud à qui ouais c'est le moment
important de cette partie ah ça fait
plaisir un des parties comme ça vraiment
c'est parce que tout peut arriver là les
deux joueurs peuvent gagner il peut y
avoir nul là c'est non là il peut plus
ça peut être que des Poké gagnant tu vas
voir non non c'est trop ça peut avoir du
foot manger six se prendre les pions de
qui partent après
là c'est sur le fil du rasoir non mais
cavaliers
non mais c'est fou projet si là faut
prendre des quatre c'est pas clair non
mais il peut non non
les meilleurs des meilleurs là ils ont
été sélectionnés ils ont fait des gros
mots pour moi c'est la meilleure
c'est clairement les meilleurs non mais
c'est les deux plus fort
du monde c'est les deux meilleurs là
pour moi c'est les deux meilleurs du
monde ouais non mais
non mais Yann c'était le meilleur et
sur les parties qui montrent là les
trois dernières c'est juste incroyable
on a en face de nous deux meilleurs
joueurs du monde point barre là c'est il
y a pas de il y a plus de débat là ça ça
tape fort des deux côtés
non mais Magnus il est intrinsèquement
peut-être plus fort échiquellement mais
si la plus envie de jouer la préparation
physique ce serait comme si un joueur de
tennis il arrête de vouloir s'entraîner
et tu dis c'est le meilleur du monde
alors qu'il peut plus taper dans Fin ok
non non oui non non mais
c'est pour lui qui va gagner il sera
champion du monde il y a aucun doute
là-dessus mais je veux dire on a c'est
pas un match c'est pas ou le deuxième il
va jouer le 10e tu vois non non non là
c'est c'est les deux meilleurs points
bas
si Ding perdait comme il a perdu sur ces
deux premières parties on aurait pu dire
quelque chose oui bon dépassait mais là
aujourd'hui il faut y aller pour jouer
comme ça
clairement
moi j'ai jamais été à ce niveau là de
deux troisièmes mondial mais j'étais pas
très loin quand même donc même pour moi
c'est impressionnant là tu étais 7 ou 8
je sais pas j'étais j'étais fort mais
c'est déjà pas mal hein
en fait ils ont rien du tout il l'a
regardé en fait oui bon il a foutranger
six les deux meilleurs joueurs du monde
en fait ils ont rien quoi
oh c'est trop
c'est trop ni l'un ni l'autre quoi
[Rires]
c'est trop j'étais sûr qu'il avait en
fait ils ont pas grand chose
ça clique totalement au hasard en fait
quoi ouais en fait tout ce qu'on vient
de dire depuis à 20 minutes c'est ouais
bon en fait Magnus c'est nettement
au-dessus
non mais ça peut importe mais
du coup c'est jeu pour trois résultats
alors dit d'un avantage noir maintenant
alors encore le dame D8 je comprends
qu'il avait pas ouais mais là il doit
enfin là il doit trouver quand même
enfin
surtout si tu fais ces trois en plus non
en fait c'est du title tu sais du TT
avec un peu plus de temps quoi c'est du
clic là c'est dur les échecs là
ça montre à quel point c'est dur
[Musique]
esses
il comptait les poids en fait sur
l'échiquier j'ai un point de plus que
toi en fait
ouais bah voilà faites du calcul du
calcul du calcul à tous les niveaux il y
a que ça qui joue en fait c'est un jeu
de calcul
er
tu la sens la victoire de Ding là se
dessiner
C3 alors C3 portorage 4 j'aime pas du
tout ça pour le coup mais regarde Yann
qui s'est levé il est beaucoup plus
nerveux que Dink il continue à jouer
avec aussi peu de temps à les jeter du
temps à la poubelle pour aller en salle
de repos ça démontre une nouvelle fois
de la nervosité chez chez Yan il doit
pas être bien mais c'est bizarre parce
qu'il avait l'air d'être tellement bien
il faisait des têtes un peu
parce qu'en fait tu avais l'impression
que c'était du parram et tout d'un coup
tout d'un oui en fait c'est vraiment du
paramourait c'est 100% paravent en fait
il est très bien puis tu vois tu sais
pas pourquoi
mais est-ce que ça peut faire est-ce
qu'il peut fermer faire nul genre sans
trop de problèmes avec les Blancs
ce que là tu as envie de faire rien
d'effacer la partie en fait on a quand
même un on a un pion de il y a un pion
pour la qualité en fait il y a plus que
ça parce qu'il y a deux sur le côté
eldam c'est pas vraiment un pion
ça compte comme moi puis le fou il a
quand même bien fort en le fauteuil par
exemple si je dis pas de conneries
on n'a pas trop envie d'aller en finale
il faut prendre je suis pas complètement
sûr
[Musique]
bêtement après avoir si affou frangé 6 x
si on peut
on sait bien il va bouger le fou il va
les soins à 6 on s'est vite
ah c'est ouais je suis pas si on fait
pour Yann quand même non non ça doit
aller il va la tenir oui ouais
il peut même la gagner en vrai ouais
est-ce qu'on reverrait pas vite fait
cette variante comprendre
c'est le moment c'est le moment de après
ils ont vraiment rien vu en fait de ça
c'est le moment pour eux c'était
te reprends F4 donc si tout reprend F4
vous prend F4 on gagne une pièce ça
c'est facile donc faut prendre 5
maintenant si on fait puis on prend des
4 il fait et il a un pion de plus
ça va pas mais ici on avait l'incroyable
il faut prendre J6 menace d'un point
cette mat donc si f français 6 tout
reprend F8 reprend F8 et on prend la
tour on a une qualité de plus c'est pas
si dur c'est pas si dur franchement et
sur HG puis on prend des 4 si il fait
fout prend F4 F6 et on m'attend H8 non
c'est pas ça c'est possible franchement
non ça c'était franchement trouvable
c'était dur à voir pour Ding qui joue
quand tu joues
mais là n'est pas il devait avoir il
doit avoir un prêt c'est pas alors
peut-être qu'ils sont allés plus loin
mais non parce que parce qu'ici ça peut
être que mieux pour les noirs ou nuls
alors que l'autre au contraire
ils ont raté
il y a des gens qui l'ont été ouais pas
moi mais certaines personnes je pense
qu'il est loin mais bon tu étais ça joue
très très fort parfois
c'est au dessus du Championnat du Monde
ok oui
ouais mais là c'est même pas si tu sais
qu'il y a un gars c'est pas si dur enfin
le thème faut prendre ici c'est pas si
ça gagne pas attention ça gagne pas
mais c'est juste que c'est mieux que ce
comparativement c'est mieux que ça bah
de toute façon ils vont le dire après la
partie enfin il le dira peut-être que
Ding l'avait après quand il a joué
pourquoi parce que généralement
ils sont quand même beaucoup ordi ordi
dans les conférences de presse et là
comme ça donnait pas le gain c'est pas
sûr qu'il demande en fait
je suis Haïd demande quand il y a un
gain raté généralement mais là comme
c'est juste une autre variante bah
beaucoup plus intéressante et proche de
gains mais des fois ils en parlent pas
du tout ouais non mais ça c'était
introuvable en blé de ça
c'est pas possible
il faut E4 bah normal ouais mais il joue
en fait ouais il joue pour nul là c'est
pas trop il va l'obtenir à mon avis
alors oui c'est vrai qu'il menace te
reproche 7 quand même mais peut-être oui
quoi 7
faut prendre c'est ça c'est pas facile
non plus
intermédiaire est fou ranger 6
c'est encore hyper complexe
en bas en bas parce que je crois qu'il a
joué non non
en fait
peut-être qu'il a vu peut-être qu'il a
tout vu et qu'il a vu que ça a gagné pas
de l'autre côté
trop dur
ça c'était pas obligé ah oui non
d'accord ouais c'est très très difficile
donc
ça doit quand même aller avec les noirs
il l'a fait d'ailleurs
on a une majorité de pions mais on
pourra jamais la valoriser en fait
les pions de femmes quoi
c'est les pions
contre à 2 b3c3 c'est les pions de
femmes joueurs de français
c'est très très fort contre les la
majorité
mais ça c'est sûr
moi je repars en G7 je joue à 5 et
j'attends il a la colonne des aussi
il tape ses trois tu vois si alors
vraiment en plus en tapant C3 ça veut
dire que peut-être qu'un jour il va
devoir jouer C4 dans ce cas-là tu
arrives en
D40
souvent en française oui si tu arrives à
jouer
4 ça fait un peu peur quand même tour
des cinq c'est pas
la partie est tellement compliqué
il veut Dame des 6 mettre la dame
derrière et c'est passé mais
c'est agressif comme coup j'aime bien
c'est agressif tu continues à jouer le
gars en fait
dingue c'est un joueur très agressif en
fait
en tout cas moi dans ce genre de
position je trouve c'est la meilleure
manière d'obtenir un minimal annule
c'est de continuer à attaquer
il va falloir renforcer le roi un moment
tu imagines qu'il va devoir jouer g3mg2
quelque part à essayer de se réorganiser
mais bon c'est difficile il y a ces
trois en l'air il y a en l'air
je pense que c'est plus facile à jouer
avec les Noirs ça
avance
ouais je sais pas ouais tu me diras tu
menaces là
les échanges de dames font mal pour les
pour les noirs
il nous reste combien de coups il nous
reste 13 coups et c'est quoi c'est 19
minutes contre 15 ok ils ont encore un
peu de temps par contre c'est très
bizarre de jouer sans rajoutant les
gens et tout d'un coup tu peux te
retrouver dans longtemps mais avant
c'est plus
traditionnels
la tradition donc c'est tradition
non mais c'est vrai c'est la raison pour
de vrai c'est je trolls pas c'est plus
traditionnel on nous fait roi chien il y
a pas de foufranche dedans
mais du coup tu es content d'avoir
introduit tour des cinq dans cette ligne
ce que le roi il est un peu moins bien
non je crois que non non je suis pas moi
j'aime bien la tour en 8
[Musique]
j'ai trois fous des deux en plus ah oui
c'est pour ça qu'il fait le tour des
cinq ah oui incroyable
mais après j'aime pas trop le fou F4
je pense ça désorganise
4 est-ce qu'on peut j'ai trois il fait
des deux par exemple j'ai trois
fous des deux tours d'air même comme ça
je suis pas sûr
tu es content qu'il est 1000 rond H1 il
a peut-être un peu moins bien H1 quand
j'ai un du coup
D2 pas facile à gérer sur l'échiquier
mais moi je trouve que c'est plus facile
à jouer au noir mais après
j'ai l'impression que tu as plus de
plans avec les Noirs là tu as plus de
scénarios qui peuvent bien se passer
moins de choses à contrôler
tu me diras
la société
pour Yann
il est en train de le rattraper
et tout ça c'est parti du cavalier F6
donc l'ouverture
en fait ça sera peut-être mon prochain
cours
mais cavalier de 2 c'est bizarre dans
l'ouverture parce que c'est vraiment
très
enfin c'est le coup de femme tu me diras
bon coup
de toute façon c'est fort ça fait mal ça
fait mal
tour des cinq bon à noter qu'il y a pas
les tours prend aussi dans aucun cas
quand même le mettre
et tu reprends ici ce marche pas parce
que on défend avec la meuf 7
quand même il y a peut-être des gens qui
voient cette tactique mais elle ne
marche pas
en tout cas là on va avoir une
demi-heure de folie parce qu'en 12 coups
il va s'en passer des choses dans cette
position
[Musique]
oui qu'est-ce qui se passe sur C4 on a
fout des catéchèques intermédiaires et
en fait on n'est pas content d'avoir
provoqué ça parce que maintenant
regardez les noirs peuvent vont pouvoir
pousser 5 et 5 on n'est pas très content
et nos pions sont complètement bloqués à
l'aile dame attends je crois que j'ai
une suggestion c'était de jouer G4 et je
me demande si c'est si bête
l'idée c'est de bloquer il a fait
tourage 4 OK
[Musique]
c'est pas
il retire des F5 peut-être F5
c'est une vraie menace ou pas
dans les lignes qu'on voit les ordies
aiment bien ils aiment bien laisser tout
reprendre H7 tout à l'heure
en fait
on menace de rester quand même dans le
temps de te faire tourner et te mater
attention de ne pas se prendre des tours
prend F7 ouais
il va jouer à 5 ici F5 on veut pas alors
on veut pas jouer F5 hein parce que
regardez quand vous jouez F5 vous vous
mettez le pion après derrière faudra
avoir le temps d'enchaîner avec cinq
quatre
je crois
et surtout reproche 7 en fait
la tour elle s'enfer un peu la barre
c'est peut-être tu auras4 c'est risqué
ce qu'elle ressort plus de H7 en fait
c'est ça le truc
donc si d'amener si tu rachète tourner
un c'est fini
c'est pas introuvable
l'avantage que tu as quand tu joues
cette ligne avec les Noirs c'est que tu
sais que tu peux pas perdre en plus là
regardez c'est vraiment mat quoi c'est
trois menaces
et encore un fou qui défend et qui
attaque ah qui protège encore un tout
petit peu mais je pense que
que j'ai 5 il y a encore d'avocats
ça a l'air sympa
ça a l'air de suffire
être c'est un peu long
après il va pouvoir revenir Dame des
Sixt rocade au pire il réfléchit là il a
il va le faire je pense qu'il va faire
Dame des 6 ans c'est vrai qu'il joue que
des coups il a joué ouh là là
c'est dur là
c'est très dur et plus 15 minutes
c'est dur tu la sens la défaite de dépôt
l'arrivée ça joue encore non mais oui
mais est-ce que tu la sens arriver alors
attends peut-être dame 3
pourquoi pas
[Musique]
tu continues dans l'idée tu veux damage
peut-être que la dame elle va être aussi
ouais non mais il va jouer
il protège H2 avec la tour il menace
d'un mâche 6 ans c'est plus cohérent non
juste pour prendre des un on tient quand
même
dame 3 h 5 alors mais attends sur
tourner dame 5
mais tu es content d'échanger j'imagine
ouais on risque pas grand chose
heureusement pour les noirs on perd le
pion mais
on est dès qu'on échange une pièce
lourde avec les Blancs on est très
contents
dans ce sens là
et maintenant revenir alors il a joué
il a joué dame 3 évidemment
il avait pas le choix tu as raison c'est
trop faible
moi je sens que va être joué c'est sûr
H5 va juste être joué
quelle pression quand même
là il le savent en plus que c'est une
position hyper importante du match après
c'est compliqué encore un parce que si
tu fais parce que il bouge pas là
5 G3
ça reste compliqué pour les deux ça
reste je pense ça reste largement dans
le tenable là
ah non ça c'est évident il est pas il
sait qu'il est pas passé très loin je
pense
non non
c'est vrai
mais c'était quand même inattendu ouais
on a un kebab qui est parti faire 5
j'ai trois j'ai 300 jolies coup là
où la pire nue regarde moi ce Punto en
C3
il y a pas de chaise boxing entre les
deux là non là c'est compliqué ouais
ça va peut-être aller
j'ai trop assez forcé il va falloir
revenir avec cette tour
et puis ça améliore un peu le roi ouais
jouer j'ai trois on peut imaginer un roi
G2 tours 2 de la F3 on améliore quand
même cette position du roi
et surtout sur Fuge pour C4 qui empêche
la tour des cinq de bouger de
ce qu'elle doit protéger ses cinq il a
bien réorganisé ses pièces là
il va la tenir
mais elle va elle va elle va être longue
cette partie
il y aura peut-être pas de ça va te
sauver je vois mal cette partie finir à
moins de 5h36 heures de jeu
personnellement alors que au 15e coup tu
disais ça va durer moins de 20 coups bah
ouais mais bon ah ça joue bien quand
même enfin
ça tient
ça tient pour l'instant ils sont à 3 3
c'est ça
de nul à moi qui propose nul au 40e
parce que ils peuvent je crois qu'à
partir du 40e coup ils ont le droit
ouais donc c'est le seul scénario mais
si il joue sans proposer nul ça va durer
tour des trois il y a pas de tour
Detroit ici Messieurs il y a dame prend
5 en fait il est il est tenu là et il a
pas envie de tourner un c'est ce que
j'ai expliqué tout à l'heure les les
échanges de pièces lourdes elles sont à
l'avantage des blancs parce qu'on a un
roi faible notamment et puis dans les
finales bon on va plus plus vite avec
nos tours
mais demain je vais pas pouvoir te
proposer la nuit le 15e pour conserver
la tradition de vie Maxime ça aurait pu
faire nul en 15 coups aujourd'hui en
plus
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a eu des nuls
rapides à l'époque à l'époque ça pouvait
ce qui était beau c'est tout peut se
passer dans cette partie il faut F6
solide
chasse la tour peut-être il peut avoir
des fougères
on a de la chance un peu quand même
toujours avoir un peu de chance dans ces
variantes par exemple ça d'un F2 sur des
deux comme français 5 prises la tour E1
tient la case 3 primordiale
[Musique]
elle leur dit propose tour à 4 moi
j'irai plutôt en C4 pour tenir
tu tiens un C3 aussi tu te tiens un truc
tu vas plutôt en C4 normalement
tu auras 4 en fait je vois pas de
scénario tu vas jouer tu reprends à 7
ouais ça va être défendu enfin mon tour
C4 ça paraît ouais il va le jouer je
pense vite
en fait c'est juste les coups normaux et
là ouais ouais si tient parce qu'il peut
il a une belle case en G2 pour le roi
quand même roi G2 tours tu tiens tu
tiens
est-ce qu'il y a une petite nul ici de
répétition ou pas
genre tout re 5 dans ma F2 Tour Eiffel 3
il va jouer quelques couleurs
il peut déjà améliorer son roi roi G7
améliorer un peu ses pièces
il n'y a pas de risque qui va il va
devoir jouer quelques coups quand même
et tour des trois pour prisser 5 prises
C5 prix c'est ça ah faut prendre ces
trois tu as tortue
si elle passe elle passe
bon après ça reste oui non mais non il
faut prendre heureusement
menace tape la tour et menace fous des
quatre donc c'est une double menace mais
le coup intermédiaire tour ces 8 échecs
très joli Kevin roi G7 et tous deux fous
des 4 et Roig G2 on n'est pas mieux mais
on n'est pas moins ni bien non plus on
va la tenir celle-là
pour ces quatre alors comment il va
pousser Ding
mais c'est fou le nombre de variantes ou
ça tient de justesse après normal ouais
c'est ta bouteille exactement Baki
10 + 0,8 pour les Noirs mais ça va faire
que nul
ouais enfin un truc c'est qu'on voit pas
vraiment on voit que c'est mieux mais on
voit pas comment percer le coffre est-ce
que Ding voit que c'est -08 est-ce que
c'est vraiment -08 déjà je pense pas en
fait
c'est avantage noir ça doit
on a un meilleur ROI on a
le matériel on est un tout petit peu
mieux matériel avec les blancs mais
comme je disais les trois contes 2 à
l'eldam ça compense largement
après ça peut il y en a un des deux qui
peut imploser dans une partie comme ça
on se rappelle dans la fameuse on nous
dit c'est c'est 0,14 oui voilà c'est
normal 0,14 c'est un peu plus en
pratique que 0,14 quand même 04 parce
que c'est pas facile mais bon pas facile
de trouver
enfin bon ça c'est les lignes d'ordi on
voit que c'est un peu mieux pour les
noirs de toute façon après la tu vois il
trouve pas non plus hein comment
c'est joli ça c'est mignon
qu'un coup comme ça ouais on serait très
très bien
meilleur coup ça va mauvais coup
d'ailleurs bah non parce que comme on
voit qu'il y a des tours
j'ai dit à 6 3 G7
d'abord mais
pions E5 ben E5 le problème c'est comme
tu peux pas enchaîner avec 4 ton pion va
être bloqué si vous pouvez faire E5 E4 à
100% tu ferais le 5 F5 le 5 F5 et 4
[Musique]
en plus ça ferme un peu le fou je sais
pas par exemple on peut regarder
mais on peut imaginer qu'après un coup
comme
j'ai 7 disons avec les noirs on joue
deux coups fou g75 même B4 du coup tu
ouvres maintenant que le fou il est il
s'est un peu enfermé
j'ai pensé mais j'y ai pas du tout cru
j'ai hâte c'est pas mal H4 investir
j'aurais pas
un peu risqué ce H4 quand même il est
vraiment le gars depuis le début il joue
vraiment pour gagner ouais mais c'est
bien plus que 5 39 quand même pour 8
coups faut 9 coups faut pas oublier
qu'il y a pas de rajout hein il veut
quoi après je prends H4 quand même alors
ça c'est normal
c'est très très bien joué le 5 tours 2
le coup qu'on a envie de jouer ici il
faut prendre un H2
et tour des deux enfilade et là si on
est obligé de donner la dame ok il y a
quand même trop de pions ici la masse de
pion et les tours sont pas ont du mal à
se reconnecter c'est l'autre sans blague
parce que regarde il vient de jouer à H4
GH c'est le main il a 5 minutes pour
jouer quand même 8 coups et il réfléchit
rejette une minute à la pendule et ce
qu'il aurait pas oublié qu'il a pas 30
secondes de rajout par manque d'habitude
c'est pas facile c'est pas facile à
gérer est-ce que est-ce que il a pu
oublier qu'il avait pas les 30 secondes
parce que c'est comme tu le dis c'est
une cadence à laquelle on joue jamais
il est pas bien là il sait
il a jamais si peu de temps parce que
quand il nous reste 8 coups à 30
secondes ça fait 4 minutes
à zéro là ouais c'est comme si il y a
une seconde
en cadence habituelle avec les 30
secondes de rajout donc attention la
dîme qui laisse filer encore plus d'une
trente là bah qui est sur après GH oh là
là il a loupé il a dit il a loupé il a
loupé GH ouais mais bon fouet 5 c'est
vrai que c'est fort
pourquoi ça serait si bien pour les
noirs
il va avoir des coups facile quand même
il a gagnera pas mais à cause du temps
mais il va voir
qu'on est en train de voir déjà deux
minutes de réflexion oh il y a une
époque là il a fait une marlouterie là
oh la cata on est en train de vivre une
catastrophe mesdames et messieurs oh ça
peut se jouer autant regarde 3,25
là je suis il va avoir 20 secondes par
coup bah qui oh il a pas fou
il va pas perdre même moi je sais tu
tiens non non
il est en train de sombrer là-bas qui
ils sombres
au dernier tour de France avec avec
rogglish et Wingard qui l'attaquait quoi
à un moment donné il a explosé regarde
il explose il est de 55 Baki il a
implosé hein ouais ça va vite mais quand
tu es en train de claquer la moitié
là là il impose autant et puis regarde
épine des trucs
incroyable bah tiens regarde il sortait
tout et bon c'est trop oui on va on va
le voir comme il y a un délai sur
l'autre caméra regarde regarde la caméra
en dessous de nous regarde il va il va
on va voir le Jump regarde le Jump qui
va faire il y a un petit délai entre les
deux cas voilà il repart regarde
[Musique]
alors si il arrive à se remettre et
qu'il arrive à la
perdre autant au championnat du monde ça
fait combien de temps qu'on a pas vu ça
encore beaucoup
[Musique]
mais c'est plus qu'une 55 là les coups
sont chers
et messieurs je n'ai jamais vu ça de ma
vie Baki et il l'a pas hein
sinon tu fais ouais G7 si tu as pas fait
roi G7
ma vie mesdames et messieurs ça c'est la
pression là oh là là plus qu'une 25 oh
là là oh il a coulé incroyable
incroyable
en fait
et Messieurs l'un des plus gros
craquages de l'histoire des championnats
du monde là-bas
le mardi soir 58 secondes il a il a
abandonné là oh c'est incroyable
incroyable il a oublié peut-être qu'il y
avait pas de rajout il a oublié il va
pas être bien comment tu vas voir son
mais tu es sûr qu'il y a pas de rajout
des deux cliquer ez avec mon hasard
à 45 secondes pour jouer wikoo ça va
être dure hein
dame G3 il y a pas de fou et 5 ici
incroyable
trois tempo allez Ding il faut la tenir
allez qui veille encore une pièce sur
dix se craquage on le revoit sur le
deuxième écran regarde comme il s'assie
et c'est extraordinaire
[Musique]
le goût du sang l'odeur du sang
allez faut réussir à faire l'exploiting
ça va être dur hein c'est faisable
appartient incroyable et il craque comme
ça à la fin quoi c'est fou mais la
pression pourquoi en plus quoi ouais là
il se dit pourquoi en fait pourquoi j'ai
fait H4 pourquoi j'ai pris un risque je
crois j'ai 7 je crois assis je te rends
5 tu aurais 5 à temps je H4 plus tard
et il est plus obligé d'écrire les coups
non non on est obligé quand on a 30
secondes mais à moins de 5 minutes on
est plus obligé si on n'a pas 30
secondes si on n'a pas 30 secondes
est-ce que nepo peut faire exprès de
passer sous les 5 minutes pour ne pas
écrire pour pas montrer non
il y a dame prend ses cinq en fait ouais
juste
ouais ok
comme quoi chacun ses moments on a tous
nos moments pour craquer là
mais j'ai pu inquiet pour lui parce que
ça ressemble un peu au scénario du match
précédent alors la partie est moins
longue ou quoi mais c'est le même type
de enfin c'est un craquage une implosion
quoi
oui après attends à vérifier quand même
nous on voit leur dire on voit que
l'ordi d'un Français 5 mais
après tu menaces rien dame français 5
tours G2 Dame des trois Tour Eiffel 2
la F6 mais de toute façon ça c'est vu
qu'il était dans une Dante comme ça
[Musique]
il voyait pas
ok en tout cas c'est un match
fantastique et il est pas fini malgré ce
craquage incroyable
il aurait pu être fini si Yann perdait
aujourd'hui
de repos pour se refaire et puis c'est
pas fini encore mais je pense qu'avec 40
secondes là c'est
oh là là
quel craquage le HK tempo en plus
[Rires]
et tout ça ça part du cavalier 65
alors dame prend ses 5 qu'est-ce qui
calcule aussi
première question est-ce que si
j'échange en C5 et que je vais vous
prendre en C3 ouais mais ça c'est la
finale c'est complètement perdant
j'arrive pas avec les pions les douches
les doigts ils sont très loin là ils
sont non ils sont deux
ils sont deux mais ils sont et même
s'ils sont ensemble ils sont attends et
là il y aura un truc incroyable
quelqu'un il le dit dans le chat et là
Ding se lève pour aller aux chiottes
bah là si tu as vraiment trop envie de
pisser tu te pisse dessus enfin mais
réellement genre premier degré là tu as
plus le choix oh mon pote dans un cas
comme comme grichou qui
quand il lui propose un échange de dames
qui est très bien progressé
il les change pas et quand il lui pose
la question mais pourquoi tu as pas
échangé les dames je suis juste perdre
autant en fait c'est une seconde pour
jouer il avait pas le temps d'accepter
ça peut être pareil
trop loin
G2 et dame D3 ici je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de coups déjà
mais notamment tout rêve de
moi j'ai deux dames des trois Tour
Eiffel 2 je vois pas là il y a plus rien
parce que ouais on est trop fort on tape
600 plus sur les dames bien tu reprends
F6 son contrôle la case G1
on l'avait dit que tout pouvait arriver
dans cette partie
mais c'est pire que ce qu'on pensait là
il va réfléchir parce qu'il a beaucoup
de coups là je pense beaucoup
il y a même dame E3 en fait tout gagne
ici
incroyable scénario ça j'ai vraiment
jamais vu j'ai pas mémoire dans une
partie si importante surtout F2 d'un
bien
au contraire là il s'est passé quelque
chose aujourd'hui et puis c'est pas fini
il reste cinq parties non
c'est juste dur même de trouver un coup
là ça tombe ça
des petites gorgées d'eau qui tombent
plus que 28 secondes après c'est pas
mérité il avait fait une belle partie
quand même
ça joue sur les nerfs aussi ça fait
partie du jeu
18 il fait roi G7 bien joué encore un
coup à trouver la peut-être pour la Tour
Eiffel
tour F3
et ça va devoir abandonner côté Ding ça
va jouer encore deux trois coups
tellement pas mérité ouais mais les six
les nerfs font partie du jeu
facile à
faire mal à la tête donc il y aura bien
un title il y aura bien un title pas
forcément pour me
regarde il tombe
dame français 3 et il abandonne
c'est terminé mesdames et messieurs
c'est trop
victoire de Yann aux forceps
elle fait tellement mal je trouve le
scénario il est
terrible pour Ding non mais quand il va
revoir
pourquoi je joue H4 c'est terrible parce
que vraiment enfin après j'ai
trouvé 5 c'était bien pour lui mais s'il
faut l'avoir avant quoi juste la voir
avant
les deux meilleurs joueurs du monde à
qui bah oui c'est vrai mais genre c'est
la pression qui se mette l'un et l'autre
et il y en a un qui a craqué
F6 mais après tu joues tous les
meilleurs coups je suis d'accord avec
toi c'était une très très grosse partie
c'est hyper dur non mais je souscris
complètement à tes à tes propos mais
c'est ça me fait penser des fois tu
regardes des gros matchs de tennis c'est
7 6 6 7 6 c'est un moment donné ben il y
en a il seront 6-0 parce qu'il voilà
quoi enfin on est en plein milieu
de matchs vous inquiétez pas si vous
êtes pour là ou pour l'autre enfin
surtout si vous êtes pour Ding il peut
il peut encore revenir
après dur ouais dur parce qu'il va
falloir qu'il trouve une ouverture au
noir
je pense qu'il va pas répéter française
mais s'il va continuer à changer ok
maintenant il est il est prévenu quand
même
[Rires]
et pour ceux qui suivent Baki on se
retrouve vers les coups de 16 heures 50
à tout à l'heure les amis merci à tous
passez une bonne journée